[Musique]
he
et salut à tous et bienvenue pour cette
dernière dernière ronde du Grand Suisse
F on arrive déjà déjà à la fin et j'ai
l'impression que ça a commencé hier on n
pas vu le temps passer et et journé à
gros enjeu gros en aujourd'hui avec donc
trois joueurs en tête Ikar
Nakamura euh iipinko et vidit euh chacun
ayant ses chances pour se qualifier mais
il y aura que deux
sésames que de Cesam mais il y a qu'une
partie où ça joue et ça y est c'est
lancé du côté d'ikarou ikarou notre
joueur aujourd'hui Fab alors on espère
quoi aujourd'hui pouraro est-ce qu'on
espère une nulle et reposer quelque part
sur la partie erigisi euh près de que
euh vidite prè de que pardon on aura
besoin d'une nulle ou est-ce qu'on
espère carrément une victoire au noir di
cararou histoire de mettre tout le monde
d'accord bah écoute une victoire c'est
réglé mais objectivement nul c'est un
bon résultat en tout cas ikarou qui
dégaine la Sicilienne Fab choix
peut-être étonnant on sait qu'il est
capable de jouer E4 E5 4 contrôle le
centre 5 qui répond par le contrôle de
centre et là il fait un contrôle du
centre de côté quelque part exactement
alors peut-être une cal peut-être une
cheniikof ça me je pencherai vers SNE
mais je sais pas ce qu'il a en têteal
calche fa il te rend
hommage
Fabien ilavait déjà joué contre dominges
il y a quelques
temps on va voir joue donc5 bon
d66ck et pour moi sur D6 le plus fort
c'est
C3 C4 c'est jouable évidemment c la
partie l'autre jour mais ça va bien C3
c'est le coup pour tenter
quoi4 ça sera un des deux coups enfin
après il y a d'autres coups qui existent
tu peux jouer F C4 tu peux jouer à4 tu
peux jouer F3 tu peux jouer ce que tu as
envie mais c'est tous des coups plutôt
inférieurs en
général chez santoch il y a eu
D4 chez Guiry il y a eu des qu
ok
[Musique]
écoute cavalier 1 A3 fa ok bon benah
petite ligne alors il y a pas une
transposition sur A6 cavalier C3 euh si
envie oui par que genre sur cavalier C3
est-ce que c'est à 6 oui il faut jouer à
6 et du coup il faut gager à 3 h et du
coup ça revient pas juste au même bah
peut-être que tu évite que les n F C F6
pour jouer chez sneakof à ce momentl
mais mais bon ok à 6 ça paraî juste
logique parce que les Blancs veulent
jouer k C4
donc ça évite peut-être un un truc quoi
vite
[Musique]
fait mais j'ai pas accent de Brooklyn
mais est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu
la vidéo de bappé qui prend l'accent
texant complètement au
hasard non attends je la fait
écouter je sais pas si vous pourrez
l'entendre un tout petit peu de loin
mais
elle est excellente il a fait à Caval C3
et là le coup à la mode c'est fou 6 le
coup que j'ai mis dans le dernier DVD
vous PZ la chercher de votre côté mais
B5 est jouable F 7 est
jouable
mais je pense c'est pas lui non si c'est
lui c'est lui physiquement je vois mais
non mais c'est lui elle est connu
l'intervie en fait ok juste a personne
qui comprend pourquoi tout d'un coup
enfun coup il prend l'accent sa pas
pouroi donc F 6 voilà B le coup à la
mode sur quoi on s'attend à cavalier C4
c'est pas c'est c'est c'est sorti enfin
elle est ancienne la
vidéo non je sais pas pourquoi il fait
ça ouais tout d'un coup il ou tu ve
prend avec son texant qu il est là quoi
il a pas pu voir le DVD il est pas sorti
on parlait l'autre jour il sortira cour
en 2024 je pense mais donc k C4 et tour
B8 le C à la mode alors pareil he pas
sûr qu'il joue tour B8 mais c'est c'est
la grosse ligne et sur tour B8 du
coup il y a quelques idées jouables pour
les blancs évidemment don fou3 qui
paraît débile mais qui est pas mal euh
ou euh ou euh ou juste cavalier
O3 en tout cas Naka qui qui surprend
c'est quoi les enjeux de la calache bah
basiquement tu gagnes du temps de
développement avec les noir en faisant
bouger 50 fois le cavalier mais euh tu
t'es fait un défaut de structure de pion
mais comme on voit dans la ch snickof ou
quoi avec ce pion arrière la case D5 et
donc tu veux que le dynamisme
compense ce défaut de structure à long
terme et aussi tu es très heureux avec
les noir si tu fais sauter le centre
blanc et si tu arrives par exemple à
faire la poussée D6 D5 c'est parfait
euh normalement les blan te laissent pas
faire hein s'il jouent bien mais ils
doivent compter dessus tout le long
alors pourquoi pas tour C8 non tour C8
ça doit être un coup hein mais en fait
l'idée de tour B8 qui paraît mystérieux
c'est de contrôler la caisse B6 euh avec
B5 on a besoin al ok il joue une autre
ligne ave kf6 très bien
euh et j'imagine qu'il peut y avoir fou
G5 euh parce qu'en fait si on fait B5
tout de suite juste pour dire en deux
mots le problème enfin il est pas grand
mais cavalier E3 en fait le jour où tuas
un pion en B5 tu dois toujours toujours
toujours regarder s'il y a a 4 pour les
blancs donc tuas une structure un peu
plus faible quelque part alors que T B8
tu essayes de contrôler enfin d'suder
les blancs de jouer sur B6 parce que tu
as B5 à tout moment et tu as pas fait B5
donc c'est un coup tour un peu pourri
mais pour éviter un problème de
structure B3 tuas B5 quoi c'est
exactement ça et le cavalier d'aller en
3 il ser rend des deux
euh donc oui F G 5 ça tombe dans une che
sneakof
exactement mais d'ailleurs l'idée que
j'avais perso tiens je peux vous la
partager euh donc tour B8 en fait fou E3
est beaucoup moins con prévu mais
incroyable parce qu'en fait tu te dis
c'est complètement pourri parce que je
fais B5 C D2 et euh et cavalier F6 et je
vais faire D5 quoi sauf que là il y a un
coup qui est fort pour les blancs c'est
A4 et sur B4 C D5 tu perds un pion au
centre mais tu prends A6 et bon c'est
mieux blanc à cause du pion à passer et
cetera et cetera euh du coup enfin tour
B8 F E3
euh genre B5 qui D2 le coup des ordis
c'est de jouer avec F5 mais bon moi
j'étais pas fan jouable mais je pensais
à faire quialier F6 ici et genre le
meilleur coup des ordi c'est fou G5 mais
en fait ce serait la même position que
Naka avec tour B8 en plus qui peut pas
être mal quand même euh après tout ce
que tu as dit j'ai une question sur le
coup de d'I du coup le A4 est-ce que
c'est pas un peu bizarre parce que tu
avais dit A4 enfin de toute façon avec
cl on nait pas forcément envie de jouer
B5 et là il vient de jouer A4 lui de
gter de cœur ouais c'est un peu
bizarre ça existe sur T B8 ce coup mais
en fait on peut essayer de jouer avec D5
en force je pense
euh donc
c'est est-ce qui je sais pas est-ce que
D5 tout de suite ou deuxème option fait
k B4 et on va y arriver quand même qu'ir
50 pièces dessus donc donc je sais pas
je vais la regarder ça doit être sa prép
de toute façon ah mais il a joué très
vite donc il doit connaître avoir une
petite idée mais mais genre visuellement
c'est bizarre parce que B5 c'est pas
forcément l'idée et du coup il joue A4
qui empêche B5 qu'on voulait pas jouer
je seraai parti sur eu à cé je seraai
parti sur F G5 il y a une idée
hein en M absolu bah s'il veut aller
jouer les candidats oui mais après euh
aès il fait ce qu'il veut Heins il fait
ce qu'il veut ouais il peut se dire que
Naka est en must wiwin aussi enfin il
peut vouloir temporiser et voir si Naka
en mustwin il a fait tour C8 du coup
Naka mais A4 pour moi c'est une
nouveauté enfin j'ai pas de partie
dessus ok mais Naka avait l'air de
connaître hein sil a fait tour C tempo
c'est qu'il connaissait
il est hyper bien préparé Naka oui il a
une belle équipe qui travaille avec
lui moi je fais juste monter l'ordi dans
la position précédente parce que pour
l'instant a 4 est pas dans le top 3 des
coup s'il a joué à 4 pour jouer une
nouveauté pour surprendre et Naka lui
fait tour C8 tempo et qui connait c'est
pas une bonne nouvelle pour
ici
dis que tour c'est théorique selon la
base lit alors attention avec la base
c'est dans la base l le problème ENF
c'est pas un problème mais c'est qu'il a
toutes les parties de tout le monde qui
sont dedans donc non mais via les ordres
de coup ça rpose en quelque chose et
donc t C8 ça va en fait k B4 mon ord
aime
bien et T C8 c'est le coup principal il
est
correct ça va c'est un po moins précis
mais rejouable ok tour
C8 non par transposition fou G5 ou C 3
probable on fou G5 quand même euh ouais
bon alors pourquoi pas l'avir fait avant
je sais pas et fou G5 le coup qui semble
bien c'est CAH B4 pour attaquer le CAH
C4
euh donc soit tu le mets E3 soit tu
prends d'abord un F6 et tu et tu vends
le TR après euh bon fa F6 façon
F6 cavalier3 et tu peux juste faire bon
fait ça dépend de ton développement soit
tu fais dame D8 tu reviens et tu veux
faire fou7 soit tu fais
G6 att quel'un qui on pas la bonne ronde
en haut à droite ouais
c'esti on va mettre le
11 bon la partie ça va jouer mais
normalement c'est assez solide pour
Naka pas vraiment de
problème on va voir ouais on va voir ce
qu'il nous en fout donc bon les vite
fait bon ça c'est juste le début
c'estaccepter
ok après si il a des vélités mais après
si tu vois Guir qui gagne tu dévéles tu
tu as moins de véléité quoi ouais ouais
bon pour faire simple pour ceux qui ont
pas trop suivi donc il y a trois joueurs
en tête il y a que deux places
qualificatives donc bon il y aura
forcément un desessu au moins et à
l'heure actuelle si les trois font les
mêmes résultats enfin si ou qu' a trois
nul les qualifiés ça sera Naka et
sipenko donc vidit en fait il faut qu'il
fasse mieux que au moins un des deux
joueurs donc il peut espérer bah faire
nul et se dire bon ben j'espère qu'il en
a un des deux qui perd mais après si
vous sont des St en main faut gagner
après ça suffirait pas si et si Penko
gagnait les clé noire contre contre
Guiry et nak gagner clé noir contre ici
mais à ce momentl bon qu'est-ce que tu
ve faire c'est la vie mais c'est pour ça
qu'on imaginait que vidit allait pas
fermer le jeu essayer de gagner mais tu
es pas obligé de te t'envoyer en l'air
non plus tu peux avoir aussi une
surprise un autre qui perd d'ailleurs
mec à 7 point une chance bah surtout prê
de que ouais qui a le meilleur départage
mais en fait oui il y a toujours des
possibilités
quoi mais prê que celui s'il gagne il
est quasi sûr de passer mais bon en jant
le G accepté c'est juste qu'il joue
solide et il espère que VI fasse le con
oui c'est pour ça que j'ai dis c'est
c'est pas une ouverture pour gagner le
gambam accepter mais tu peux gagner par
la force des choses parce que l'autre
veut te battre ça
oui mais sipenco c'est pas dit que il
perd pas hein non non non bien sûr il a
une partie à jouer
gu qui est motivé alors il pourra pas
passer sur ce tourno gu mais des points
ça fait deux choses pour lui fait des
points gagn toute façon et en plus ça
lui fait des points à la course la race
donc il t sa chance
quo d'ailleurs hier il s arraché pour
gagner une partie avec les no contre
nan écoute s g celleel il a fait un beau
tournoi de
rien sans vraiment jouer les premiers
rôles mais en étant solide en marquant
des points en perdant jamais voilà
quoi ah il est plus rassurant que fouja
en oui son niveau est donc SS ont que 10
points d'écart avant la SLE
field bon après firouja faudrait qu'il
fasse des nuls tout le temps la
singlefield qui joue contre nature mais
tu joues
pour faire je sais je sais pas mais il
faut qu'il fasse
quoi bah qui vise combien niveau K il
vise peut-être dans les 12 13000 pas
énorme avant
impôt euh
ouais ben écoute on verra le classement
final on pourra vous répondre après coup
hein mais on avait vu la liste des prix
ouais c'est V qu'il y a moins d'argent
que
prévu non mais dans un tournoi comme ça
important par rapport à des tournois sur
Internet où tu es tout seul chez toi à
jouer quoi donc c'est un peu surprenant
effectivement mais d'unutre côté tu as
ton voyage payé non oui mais quand tu es
chez toi tu tu es payé chez toi quoi
enfin mais oui ils onont pas de frais
hein attention hôtel voyage machin ça va
c'est pas donc tu es tu es heureux de
prendre prendre 12 cas c'est
pas c'est beau façon qu'on l'a souvent
dit hein probablement les échecs c'est
le sport le mieux pay per en fonction de
l'audience si tu fais un
ratio c'est beau
ouais personne regarde et il y a quand
même pas mal d'argent mine de rien alors
c'est pas des millions à la gagne mais
bon tu cumules tout tu invites tout le
monde tu fais
machin quand même c'est beau
ouais espérons que ça dure Fab mais
c'est pas parti pour pas durer ça fait
un moment que ça dure déjà
h
s bah sûr de rien mais je veux dire je
te parle en ratio après bah faudrait que
tu comptes le nombre de tickets vendus
et de spectateurs qui vont voir
l'événement par rapport à ce que tu as
au foot quand tu remplis les stades de
80000 personnes et cetera et après on
voit mais je connais pas grand
monde de Man pour assister à ça en
payant son billet quoi
ça c'est pas le truc le plus raménateche
genre les clubs machin et tout mais tant
mieux non non mais il a joué un truc qui
qui existe
juste je sais pas pourquoi il enchaîne
pas en fait parce que je ve dire tour C8
dans la position c'est le coup principal
mais c'est son à4 moi qui m'a surpris je
m'attendais clairement à fou G5 mais de
très
[Musique]
loin qui est le coup voilà qui transpose
dans une souveraine de la ch sneakof et
qui qui est jouable c'est mamedov qui
l'a joué récemment alors après est-ce
que il peut regarder ce qui se passe
autour un petit peu pour voir si ça vaut
le coup pour lui de tout risquer non
mais qui risque enfin je s'en fout que
tu que tu gagnes tu fasses une que tu
perdes enfin fais ce que tu veux hein
c'est c'estit life mais
[Musique]
euh je comprendrai pas quoi enfin qu'il
doit essayer après je sais pas à quel
point il doit risquer jusqu'à quand et
puis un moment si c'est égal c'est égal
tu vas rien faire bah tu vas pas perdre
pour perdre que qu'après six coups enfin
ne9u coups
tu déjà tu te résignes à plus vouloir
gagner c'est peut-être la partie de sa
vie en fait
[Musique]
hein ça Mme pas dire que ça suffit pour
malheureusement pour lui même en gagnant
il est sûr de rien mais mais il doit il
doit essayer quoi d' comme tu parlais de
places j'ai regardé ce matin il reste 9
places pour pour la BUP 3 spectateur il
reste plus que 9 places c'est vraiment
très très peu he Fab c'est ah ouais
ouais bah c'est bah c'est bon que tout
soit parti si vite euh donc ça va être
guichet fermé ça va être un guichet
fermé
ouais il soldout je crois que c'est les
places joueurs les places spectateurs en
tout cas ce matin c'était pas soldout
mais peut-être qu'il y a des fous qui
sont chauffés et qui ont sold hein mais
the French Fighter je me méfie parce
qu'il peut raconter un peu n'importe
quoi parfois il dis si
si comme je dis hein c'est il peut avoir
raison mais juste pe c'est lui qui qui
acheté qui acheté les ne9u places quoi
je sais qu'il peut être un peu
foufou mais je le crois mais quand même
je
vérifie non il reste des PL spectateurs
je dit il est un peu
foufou
ouis c'est ça il en reste
neu il dit NON NON bah si si si si
spectateur he pas les plac
joueursch chez moi bah tu dois être sur
les places joueurs spectateur il en
reste frère à moins qu'il y a un bug
hein peut-être que tu en as 10 dans ton
panier du coup ça te fait croire
ça
il aa rest roquet qui a qui a le seum il
est un pe arriv un un peu trop tard et
oui il en avait mis trop dans son panier
ou je t dis il est un peu
foufou qu place spectateur il y avait
125 places
spectateurs et 100 places joueurs 116
qui sont
partis sur les 216 en tout c'est pas
mal mais ce que je disais hier si on
faisait vraiment du marketing machin
qu'on avait des gros joueurs quand on
disait remplir 1000 places 1000
personnes pour des échecs c'est
impossible
franchement c'est largement faisable tu
fais un bel événement je crois que c'est
facile même enfin pas pour tout le monde
maisis toi tu arriver facilement moi
j'arriverai
facilement
ouais ouais non c'est pas si
dur for ça croire que c'est difficile
puisque les tournois
comme le grand Suisse il remplissent
même les places gratuites entre
guillemets il réussissent pas à les
donner visite ça déjà TR les RE bon ben
il joue joue la petite finale non non
mais il joue pour la petite finale ouais
mais bon ça on l'a déjà vu bon en gros
il va essayer de mettre le fou en F3
donc enlever son cavalier alors soit en
E5 soit aller en D2 B3 ça peut être une
manœuvre pour peut-être aller vers A5
faut F3 et cetera c'est mais c'est le
truc safe de jouer ça hein avec les
Blancs évidemment mais du coup près de
que doit être vert que lui joue ça enfin
s'il espère avoir une chance de gain
parce que tu tu l'espoir d' noir de
gagner he en jouant ça
h euh du coup vidit espère espère que
Guiry va va
torpiller mais il doit avoir une info
que Guiry va jouer à fond par qu'il se
connaissent bien les deux
ouais ça veut pas dire qu'il va gagner
ça veut dire qu'il va essayer mais il
doit peut-être qu'il lui a dit moi
j'essaye à fond et du coup j'ai
peut-être beaucoup plus de chance de
battre un tel que toi tu
vois toi contre prê que déjà nul déjà
pas mal déjà pas mal tu sais
joue qui B qui B qui joue Levon mais on
pense ça va être nul aussi parce que
Levon en fait je crois qu'il est devenu
secondant là je sais plus de qui
d'ailleurs ah ok mais il a dit qu' avait
plus rien à faire en fait ah mais ça se
voit je savais pas qu'it second de qui
ou de quoi mais en plus il a dit de qui
j'ai juste oublié ah ok je dire je vois
très bien dans comme il joue quoi bah
d'ailleurs son classement drastiquement
déjà baissé quoi ça pas traîné donc
voilà après Levon il va rester autour de
2007 sans faire d'efforts par sa classe
naturel mais
euh mais il va pas chercher à se faire
mal à la tête plus que ça
quoi donc la backup Paris hein à côté du
Louvre
alle
spot
prends une passe PP Crepin ben écoute
dépêche-toi quand même he parce qu'on
vient d'en parler s'il en reste plus que
neu ça peut ça peut partir très vite
h c'est sold g pour pour jouer ce qu' le
minimum il y a pas de minimum en fait
c'est un tournoi ouvert à tout le monde
mais là il y a plus de place enfin pour
le coup non après s'il y a des gens qui
annulent on en remettra très
sporadiquement enfin bah oui oui s'il y
en a des nouvelles c'est annulation mais
bon ça arrive he souvent qu'il y a une
ou deux personnes qui annulent mais mais
il faut pas attendre qu' ait 15
quoi non puis en plus il déjà des gens
qui m'ont écrit pour en avoir une si ça
annule
donc
bon qui su
quoi ben tant mieux ça fait nos
affaires
mais je crois qu'on est le seul tournoi
en France à vendre des places d'ailleurs
spectateur ENF je connais pas d'autres
tournois qui fassent ça non non c'est
vrai la est organisé entièrement par toi
et ton équipe
ouais enfin c'est surtout moi et lpot en
fait grosso modo c'est moi
spot
mais bon après organiser je sais pas il
y a pas grandchose à organ enfin pas
grand chose y a beaucoup de choses
organisé mais en soit c'est que de la
technique informatique en fait et de la
régie mais sinon dans ma foi que les
serveur tour il tourn quoifin oui bah
oui mis à part des trucs très techniques
à faire il y a pas grand-chose à faire
en soi enfin tu as beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent sur tout pour vérifier que
le matérial marche des caméramans
des des techniciens à la
Régie des gens qui s'occupent enfin tout
ce qui est côté infrastructure un mec
qui fait la sécurité enfin tu vois il y
a beaucoup de gens qui travaillent aussi
comment dire plus ça en
fait mais c'est
pas
ludwiig ouais mais ludwiig je compte
plus comme régie en fait enfin c'est
c'est plus ça au niveau des échecs en
fait il y a pas grand-chose à faire
partie se joue quoi après Fab il surtout
il prépare son jeu d'acteur je
dirais niveau administratif ah bah ouais
il y a aussi tout niveau comptabilité
administration recherche de sponsor
enfin c'est un c'est énorme en terme de
travail parce qu'on a pas d'argent
public en fait
c'est financé à hauteur de 0 % par vos
impôts ce qui est
beau bon moi pour moi Naka tout va très
bien dans sa position
ouais
B4 c'est un coup thématique dès que les
Blanc joue à 4 ça faaiblit la case le
Cali là-bas aide peut-être les Noirs à
réaliser la poussée D5 et au moins à
contrôler la case et de de tu mets une
pression sur
C2 ça peut toujours être
utile des petites tactique ici ou là
dans genre de situation
donc un tout petit tour ouais il se
passe toujours rien et là j'end que ça
récite en
face mais donc gu est chercher un
pion
et et voilà et en face bah c'est mieux
développé donc on verra ce que ça donne
et puis bah je sais pas si tu veux qu'on
aille voir un peu d'autres parties avec
moins d'enjeu mais juste pour voir ce
qui se passe genre un peu pénible d'Er
voiruc moin en jeu non mais bon on peut
aller voir les Français c'est juste que
là en fait on a déjà vu pe faire une
pause au pire dé non mais 10 15 minutes
quoi tu dis déjà mais bon c'est les
joueurs qui nous poussent à la pause F
qui j'ai raté la
partie elle éta là j'ai vu max tout de
suiteess la petite finale nul sans
histoire ça joue
fou ça joue as il a raison
d'essayer OK
et ah bah qui quion ouais je pense
qu'ils vont faire la petite nulle quand
même ah bah oui ça c'est n c'est nul ou
ah
ou il y a pas de partie en c'est nul
quoi B c'est bien
non mais c'est très bien ça gagne des
petits points h le petit nul sans jouer
c'est toujours ce qu'on veut dommage que
chez parinov le fasse pas
ou et
euh et juste Carana Ker parce qu'il est
une microochance Ker dans un cas de
figure complètement improbable de moins
en
moins euhon tu peux voir si tu veux
VO c'est Nimzo
euh ok je crois que keer a proprement
parlé il peut pas éliminer Naka c'est
pour ça qu'il nous intéresse pas
trop en fait si Naka perd de toute façon
il sera
pas tu n'y sera pas
Naka il peut pas passer devant Naka en
fait enfin s'il passe devant Naka c'est
que Naka est éliminé de toute façon dans
ce sens il nous intéresse pas trop ouais
bon on s'intéresse à sair qu'il se
qualifie quoi juste
ouais mais il se qualifiera pas là déjà
si nul dans cette partie je crois qu'il
peut plus se
qualifier
ser un commentaire comme ça quand il se
passe rien on dit plus
rien bon après on peut parler d'autres
choses hein mais
ouais mais bon peut faire une pause
enfin tout le monde peut faire une pause
aussi
quoi c'est vrai que là depuis le début
de la partie s'est quand même pas passé
grandchose depuis la première demi-heure
non il y a eu quelques coup ouverture
théorique et puis et puis rien quoi et
puis rien
c'est une ronde sorifique pour l'instant
euh et ça va
[Musique]
se ça va se se décanter plus tard à mon
avis vers les coups de 18h30 19h vers
18h30 à ça va se décter donc surtout ne
bougez pas dans 2h30 2h40 ça devrait
commencer à se décantter
Fab bah 2h3 2h40 sur une année c'est
quand même pas grand-chose non non mais
après quand tu regardes beaucoup d'échec
moment ça pèse quoi c'est chaque jour tu
sis comme une chape de plomb qui pèse
sur toi non mais je pas de chap j'ai
rien ça
[Musique]
va c'est logique qui réfléchit la
stratégie d'ouverture là c'est pas de la
stratégie d'ouverture he ce qu'il est en
train de faire Risi je pense juste qu'il
a
il est passé à
côté peut-être discuter du choix de Naka
bah on l'a déjà fait en fait mais mais
ça peut durer longtemps puis ça reste
solide ça c'est pas c'est pas une
ouverture feol pour autant
euh non mais basiquement comme je vous
dis soit il va faire6 soit il va faire C
3 direct euh de toute façon le fou G5
est destiné à s'échanger en F6 alors
soit tu attend qu' est fou E7 et le fou
prendra soit tu veux mal placer la dame
mais tu donnes l'opportunité aux noirs
de se développer en FIAN keto avec
peut-être le fou qui rend H6 euh et au
pire les Noirs s'ils ont pas envie Dee
façon ils peuvent toujours te faire dame
D8 et fou 7 quand même donc ça va être
deux options qui vont se ressembler et
euh et voilà mais ce qui est étonnant
c'est juste que il joue à 4 un coup
quand même un peu bizarre puis tour C8
il reréfléchit pour fou G5 pu k B4 qui
re re reeréfléchit donc ça ça
semble non non mais
ou je sais pas ce qu'il fait à quoi il
pense mais
bon et tu on peut voir gu un peu ce que
ça donne au moins il un sacrifice de
pion voà on regarde
quoi prend F4 prend D8 on prend F4 et
puis on verra bien la finale qui donne
mais bon il y a il y a pas grandchose
à à regarder Fab ouais est-ce que PR3
c'est un coup
peut-être mais tu une petite pression
avec ta paire de fou pas loin d'gal mais
un
peu diser déjà
mieux je sais
pas bah mieux je sais pas c'est
compliqué mais Fabi semble fatigué là
donc hier il nous a pas fait une grande
partie
évidemment
donc c'est pas impossible que que ça
perde après nous ça nous change rien on
est d'accord bon ça change pour le
tournoi mais en fait en soit pour la
qualification de ça change rien ce que
je veux dire je revérifier une dernière
fois mais pour moi pour nous ça change
rien
ou ça change rien du tout pour
nous
mais bon enfin on est là pour savoir
qu'il se qualifie quand même quoi ah
mais il se qualifiera pas oui mais tant
qu'il est pas Z0 % je veux dire on peut
regarder un peu quoi c'est c'est juste
la table 4
ah mais je dis pas le contraire juste
que ça change rien mais après il peut se
qualifier mais se qualifie ou pas ça
change rien pour alira ça change rien
mais ça ch même pour nous en fait bah ça
fait un autre joueur au candidat as s'
fout complètement c'est ce que je c'est
exactement ce que je voulais dire on
s'en fout complètement ENF n'importe qui
se qualifie on s'en fout aussi mais oui
non mais
complètement en vrai en vrai
complètement ouais mais bon vu qu'on
suit le tournoi oui ou voilà on regarde
quoi dans le mouvement mais jeux dire il
a très peu de chance de se qualifier
ouais c'est je sais pas il alors attends
faut qu'il gagne lui je pense faut qu'il
gagne que guyy gagne et KAC perd mais
non parce que si
euhag viidit non parce en fait il va
grdit en fait mais que peut-être qu'il
fasse nul
ouais il faut que de face
nul que
Pinko perde et voilà ils s'en fout ce se
passe che oua ouais c'est ça c'est pour
ça pour Naka ça change rien en
fait faut que bienko perde quoi ça c'est
important pour lui en fait les ouais ils
sont tous supporters de gué quoi
ouais
logique en fait par que si Penko est
leader et gu peut plus se qualifier donc
en fait c'est complètement logique que
ouais tu es un mec qui sert à rien
qui prendre
des cool un
joueur très bonne idée de
cartouche que je je stream de la belotte
ou de la coinche bah ouais moi j'ai uis
longemps mais c'est pas évident de jouer
en ligne ouais il y a pas de gens qui
jouent en ligne bah puis tu me perds un
côté cool enfin faut toujours déjà
quelqu'un un partenaire avec qui tu son
système d'annonce et compagnie quoi
enfin pas juste dire des chiffres au
hasard non on veut que ikarou gagne pour
être sûr que firou passe ah mais firou
sera pas sûr qu'il passe hein mais c'est
pour que firou a une chance de passer
mais il a une bonne chance en fait si
ikarou passe voilà c'est pas c'est même
pas une chance il sera favori pour
ber alors que s'il y a pas cararou c'est
juste fini
quoi et nous en fait on que firou passe
uniquement parce qu'on commmente les
candidats et que c'est mieux fr français
à suivre pour pour nous faire un fil
rouge donc en
fait c'est important enfin si c'est
quand même plus drôle c'est mieux en soi
[Musique]
mais ce qui se passe de toute façon on
commentera quoi qu'il arrive oui c'est
juste pour nous nous en fait on veut que
soit plus marrant pour nous de monter a
un peu plus de monde que ce soit plus
suivi que
voilà c'est un peu plus sympa
mais mais dans l'autre il y a rien
[Musique]
de c'est pas aussi important que match
de la SSE quoi ah non clairement
pas plus de monde plus de Kas B après en
plus après nous on voudra vraiment qu'il
gagne les candidats parce que ça peut
vraiment nous rapporter pas mal de
caillas alors déjà ça por de la Ka salur
SAAF donc ça c'est quand même important
non mais parce que champion du monde tu
prends au moins 800000 ou 1 million
d'euros entre tout cumulé donc ça 1
million d'euros euh ça fait de l'argent
évidemment pour pour pour la France donc
déjà on soutient la France et le PIB et
Bruno le mer et tout ce que tu veux et
en plus nous si jamais il gagne les
candidats ça va faire une h des échecs
onand y aura le match championnat du
monde on a les livres en vente les
machins et tout ça nous fait aussi de
laakayas qui fait aussi de la cayas pour
enfin c'est un genre de cercle vertueux
de la Cillas quoi donc après c'est clair
que saon quelque part
ouais donc en soit ça augmente le PIB de
la France c'est bien donc là on aura
vraiment tous intérêt que que firou
gagne ça fait rentrer la kayas un peu de
partout donc on aura tous un intérêt
quoi est que gu petit menace pour lesé
par rapport à oui il peut mais après il
peut aussi se qualifier par le Grand
Prix machin enfin B on sait pas quoi
mais c'est une petite menace il y a 20
point d'cart quand même non mais juste
regardeer on verra après on compa à la
sfield là enfin déjà faut que Naka
finisse 2uxè bon on va pas parler de la
menace de machin de truc est-ce qu'il
peuvent rejouer des tournoi faire des
parties truc en décembre enfin bon au
bout d'un moment on va pas pas faire des
plans sur la comète on verra où on en
est au 1er décembre pour le moment
laissons les parties se jouer quoi parce
qu'en fait moi je pourrais truquer plein
de parties et faire passer ala même
devant carou mais après personne veut
personne veut de ton idée bah personne
veut de mon idée mais alors que mon idée
elle est imparable je fais un match en
40 parties contre alira je lui laisse
gagner 400 il prend enfin je comprends
pas en fait pourquoi personne veut veut
mettre en place ce truccl c'est
complètement
légal vite fait enfin bah qui va prouver
que les partis sont truqué en fait
ouais mais bon mais comment tu prouves
je lui demande même pas d'argent je les
donne il y a même pas il y a pas de
transaction financière il y a rien ça me
fait
plaisir qui va enfin mais personne veut
veut écouter mes plans donc au bout d'un
moment
euh légal mais pas moral oui mais légal
quand même enfin jarding s'est qualifié
comme ça au candidat la dernière fois
enfin bon les partis étaient donné pas
donné personne n' allait chercher à
savoir hein il s'est organisé des
tournois chez lui il a fait ce qu'il
voulait il est champion du monde enfin
moi je propose de faire la même chose en
France en fait j'eni absolument rien à
[__] enin il va être 3000 éo il va
être 4000 éo il va être qualifié à tous
les candidats du monde
enfin je sais pas pourquoi c'est
un
je vois pas où est le problème en fait
moi ça m'arrange personnellement qui
gagne aussi donc en soi il y a pas de
j'ai envie de faire plaisir un pote quoi
enfin ça lui fait plaisir aussi il va
jouer ple qui ça fait plaisir des gens
dans le chat bon moi
aussi en plus j'ai pas besoin de les
truquer pour les perdre exactement
Chapour
jou Ludvig contre les
ouais une
partie fa un tour à ferm de génie on
fait une cadence de génie 90 + 30 3
rondes par jour tuuras pas le droit
c'est de par jour max on joue de par
jour c'est pas
grave on joue de 9h à
9h1 et de 14h à 14 2 quoi on a le temps
de faire le petit déj un bon repas tout
on est
content un P système au bout ça pourrait
qualifier Fab ou Mazo bah même moi ça
peut me qualifier en fait enfin ah B on
peut tous se qualifier en fait tous se
qualifier en fait ouais si ça vous dit
on orgis des tournois à
l'année mais de toute façon mon plan
d'agent de joueur Fab ça fait longtemps
qu'il faut le faire hein c'est très très
fort mon truc d'agent de joueur
c'est bon on fait un tournoi des
candidats avec Full français en fait on
peut les fermer on peut complètement
fermer le système ils pourront rien ils
peuvent rien faire en fait on arrive
tout m 3200 Louis ils peuvent rien
faire en plus on ferme complètement le
truc parce
que faut qu'on laisse gagner Maxim werza
pour qu'il y en ai un qui prenne le
titre de champion du monde après on te
défonce Ding et après on notre circuit
fermé quoi entre Français entre français
mais après peut-être les autres vont
truquer des tourn aussi ça pe être
extraordinaire condition pour tour F bon
il y a pas grandchose hein il faut juste
un arbitre un arbitre une pendule non
puis voilà c'est pas non c'est facile
c'est facile compliqué non non ça tu
peux le faire n'importe où tu peux même
organiser des parties d'entraînement si
tu tu veux qui compte pour le compte
pour le hlo donc tu peux tu es même pas
obligé de faire un tourage faire partie
d'entraînement tu as besoin juste enfin
tu as besoin de rien en fait ouais tu
joues chez toi tu es comme ça hop là
donc
ouais
sinoc arbitre ben voilà en fait c'est
parfait bah let's
go pourquoi les joueurs pro Français ne
veulent pas le faire c'est une super et
je sais pas non mais l'idée est géniale
en
fait tu truces toutes les parties TR
tous les tour tu trucques tout
quoi on décide en Amond du champion du
monde en faisant de pierrefeuill on fait
comme le catch en fait tout est décidé à
l'avance on connait tous les résultats
de tous
les ce serait tellement
beau
est-ce que le jeu en vaut la chandelle
bah
largement
ah on a un deuxième
arbitre c'est tout Français ça on a de
l'or entre les mains mais on en profite
pas ouais on a pas de pétrole mais on a
des idées pour leur prendre leur
caillass
quoi en plus avec l'argent du pétrole
ils vont ils vont nous sponsoriser on va
prendre leur fric enin c'est vraiment
une idée extraordinaire mais bon ça va
pas voir le
jour non mais je crois qu'ils n'ont pas
de manière en fait pour le moment pour
éviter ça non non non ilons
pas Bul signé ouais bonne opération pour
le Pr ouais c'était pas décidé avant à
proprement parler mais tu sentais tu
savais queimment que bonne chance so le
scénario
ou bon fa ça va être le moment de faire
notre petite pause ok il s pas il s'est
pas passé grand chose de plus donc on
fait un petit tour bon là sur cette
partie là on a compris qu'on était
bloqué là il y a rien eu de plus B3 fou
B6 bon ça s'annonce être une finale au
long cours mais qui devrait peut-être se
le départ nul Guiri j'ai l'impression
qu'il fera rien contrepienco en fait une
bonne nouvelle pour nous
mais l'air de bien connaître et je le
vois pas perdre cette
finale on sait
jamais et ça c'est
Maxime bon ça va jouer
ça va
jou déjà nul c'est déjà nul caroana on
sait pas trop mais c'est pas forcément
important du coup enfin juste on se
tient au courant comme ça mais voilà
allez à tout de suite les
amis
[Musique]
he
he he he
he he
[Musique]
he
les amis il a eu deux trois coups depuis
qu'on est parti mais on revient il s'est
pas il s'est pas passé grand-chose he
c'est pour ça qu'on on préfère rester au
frais avec Fab donc il y a eu cavalier
E3 fou7 on l'a vu fou2 G4 il a gardé son
son cavalier en vis c'est bien joué fou
prend G4 doncin s prenait en E7 ça
reprenait en E3 et ça tapait sur la dame
et ça repris en G5 donc il s pas passer
grand-chose comme souvent Fab non non le
truc c'est qu'évidemment F PR 6 c'est
absolument pas un
problème puisqu'on prend de F on
consolide la case D5 qui est clé on va
pouvoir rockquer le fou G5 est activé on
va peut-être même pouvoir pousser D5
nous-même si on a besoin un jour donc
c'est pas terrible pour les blancs je
pense les Nords sont mieux et j'imagine
qu'il y a un deuxième problème c'est que
sur E5 qui donne envie je pense qu' F pr
G4 et il y a le problème de C2 j'en
avais parlé tout à l'heure que céit un
truc à vérifier quand il en B4 sur CD5
mais sûrement fou prend le3 qui prend
le3 fou prend G4 bah minimant gagner un
pion mais Rizi qui fait une partie
cataclysmique plutôt grottesque ouais
bah Naka là il finit contre deux joueurs
qui jouent deux parties grotesques mais
c'est aussi une des forces de Naka dans
les moments importants on le sait joue
bien dans les moments importants ikarou
généralement il était tombé l'an dernier
contre un gros Ding dernière ronde des
candidats qui lui aussi avait sorti sa
meilleure partie et Ding qu' a confirmé
finalement match championnat du monde
puisque dans les départages il a aussi
joué à un niveau stratosphérique donc
ikarou comme Ding liren a cette qualité
de jouer ses meilleurs échecs dans les
moments les plus importants ce qui
semble pas être le cas de nepomiashi ou
d' rigizi Fab non mais là ça se voit mal
à pendu il n'a qu même pas réfléchi une
seconde enfin il est 1h38 alors à 1h40
j'imagine qu'il est pas assis à chaque
fois donc peut-être que le temps qu'il a
dépensé c'est en étant debout
euh
donc donc ça parle tout seul quoi et
donc oui GI qui passe complètement à
côté de de la partie avec un A4 jouer à
contretemps avec fou G5 qui prend pas en
F6 aucun coup n'a de sens en fait c'est
minable non mais bon il rate il rate
hein mais bon après tu vois c'est c'est
le moment culminant du tournoi la
dernière ronde où il y a l'enjeu et en
fait tu vois bon c'est comme si tuarr en
finale de Grand chlem et puis que tu te
fais breaker enfin tu prends 6 Z0 en
faisant que des doubles fautes bon tu as
le droit quoi
mais j'ai le droit le droit donc il
prend E6 bon c'est le moins pire a
priori mais F prend et plutôt mieux pour
Naka quoi donc Naka à mon avis il aura
pas de souci alors à moins qu'il gaffe à
son tour plus tard mais il y a
absolument aucun problème dans la
position il a un bon F G5 un bon calier
B4 les cavaliers adverses sont pas de
case ou rebondir euh il y a pas de
faiblesse il y a rien enfin c'est c'est
nickel c'est une excellente position
pour lui après cas qui pourra gérer s'il
a besoin si si si nul lui suffit bah il
fera nul s'il faut qu'il aille gagné bah
il ira cravacher quoi ouais mais je
pense nul lui suffit toujoursin vu qu'il
sait qu'il a la Cartell au cas où mais
en plus les autres je les crois pas je
crois pas que ça va gagner chez cpenko
déjà ououis donc euh
ouais mais SP qu besoin que de nul pour
G pour gêner
Naka hm hm et oui il a un meilleur
départage et euh il y a quoi d'autre et
c'est ça c'est en fait c'est c'estit
est-ce qu'il va arriver à gagner cette
partie et ben il va devir travailler
viitein c'est disons pas parti pour
c'est assez équilibré mais bon on verra
quoi après je pense
que côté Naka tu as quand même envie d'
juste par principe là tu joues quand
même un petit peu ah bah ouais tu r dire
tu vas pas faire nul euh enfin parce que
des faites aussi tu es quand même
qualifié quoi qu'il en soit mais en fait
après je sais pas euh comment dire
euh j'imagine qu'ils ont un coup minimum
à jouer pour faire nul tu peux pas
proposer déjà nul quoi donc tu vas être
obligé de jouer et si ça continue sur
cette trajectoire à un moment le jouour
où tu AAS envie de faire nul bon bah tu
seras déjà peut-être trop gagnant pour
faire nul quoi donc donc on verra quoi
vite aucune chance de si enfin oui et
non il est pas vraiment mieux mais il a
encore toutes les pièces sauf les dames
surtout que son adversaire peut avoir
envie de forcer c'est g aussi un moment
donné donc voir on verra c'est C donc
bon toute façon de jouer 16 coups quoi
qu'il en soit donc il va jouer des coups
normaux raisonnabl il va
Roer il va peut-être mettre la dame en
B6 gagne mais c'est chaud dire d'un
sportif qu'il est minable tu peux dire
qu'il fait une partie minable quand Mme
il pas dit il est minable minable mais
obligé de dire que je très bien très
bonne partie pour la dernière rond bah
ça arrive de faire des parties minables
c'est pas méchant c'est un qualificatif
de la partie qu'il est en train de
jouer ça arrive c'est comme ça
hein des jours avec des jours sans
surtout avec la
pression surtout avec la pression c'est
jamais facile de bien
jouer mais bon là du coup quand tu as
les blancs que tu as joué 12 coups tu es
moins bien je sais pas comment tu vas
appeler ça appelle comme tu veux hein
partie bryante si tu as envie
mais mais bon il y a sûement un truc s
mal passé quand
même tuas pas le droit de le dire c'est
un
sportif après tu es pas à l'abri que à
un moment nakc lui-même joue un mauvais
coup car tr truc brillant il reviennent
l'ouverture qui qui est mal jouée bah
elle est mal jouée en faitf c'est c'est
factuel Naka a dit hier qu'il s'en
fichait de passer au grand Suisse parce
qu'il a les Lau et qu'en plus ça ça
empêcherait d'y aller qu'il trouve
positif car c'est un bon adversaire
oui mais bon hier il a quand même gagné
à un moment si tu veux vraiment pas
gagner tu trouves un moyen de faire
nul en Suisse on est sûr que qu' fo pas
du tout hein mais il a de bonne chance
très bonne chance enfin largement favori
mais d'ailleurs en fait il a aussi dit
dans sa vidéo nous on a regardé Ikaru
que en fait ce qui s'est passé hier
c'est que carwana il pensait qu'il
voulait faire nul et que ça l' un peu il
s'est pas trop méfié quoi pas trop méfié
ouais il pensait comme nous en fait mais
mais c'est toujours dangereux quand tu
es pas sûr que c'est nul faut quand même
être sûr de ce que tu fais
quoi
il jou peut-être plus pour le titre que
pour la Calif ça c'est vrai ouais par
contre c'est quand même 80000 balles
hein mais euh non mais je sais pas trop
il clique
quoi mais en gros oui bon s'il a une
chance de gagner une position sans trop
de risque bah genre comm il avais hier
il fera
s un truc un peu double tranchant il
séchera s'il a besoin de sécher mais là
en fait c'est juste déjà mieux c'est
aussi simple que
ça en fait je suis pas
[Musique]
sûr 25avance sur plus ah pardonusemi je
CIS que tu
parlais fait 15
12 je crois déjà beau mais fais voir sil
finit un point derrière sa peut-être
qu'il sera derrière il a 13 à l'heure
actuelle et puis a sa parti à jouer
aujourd'hui ouis mais en plus c'est an
qui
cont donc donc ok pour l'instant il y a
13 points d'écart si ça s arrêé
aujourd'hui mais il y a une partie qui
joue donc ça sera un peu moins ou un peu
plus
euh ok bon gu qui essaye on sait pas
trop ce qu'il essaye mais il essaye il a
un P de plus donc donc écoute c'est
toujours quelque chose
oui sur le site de la feed mais en fait
depuis il a joué ferou quand même déparé
le tournoi et pas tellement bien donc il
en a perdu un peu des points là il est
plus que 2765 si on compte ce qu'il a
fait euh voilà bon ça il a stress points
mais de toute façon si tu es Naka si tu
peux prendre la partie reprendre enfin
c'est quand même 5 points l d'écart et
cetera c'est sûr qu'il le prend le Punto
dame
G4 donc son idée c'est que si on fait
fou prend E3 il va prendre E6 on peut
pas mettre la dame on perd la tour donc
on va
faire non mais si pr F8 puis on prend E3
il prend C2 et forchette mais le
problème c'est qu'il y a tour F1 ouais
c'est ce que j'allais dire ouais ça va
pas ah non mais ça oui donc c'est pour
ça qu'il fait dame G4 et qu'il a pas
peur de F 3 mais a priori on va faire
dame F6 pour défendre ce P 6 toujours
défendre le fou G5 il va menacer fou pr
3 il va sûement faire grand rock il va
tenter grand
ro bon petit rock
[Musique]
euh attends et repr prend des si bon il
a juste d' prend de qui restque de faire
très mal et on peut avoir ça bon là pour
le coup première bonne décision d' j'ai
envie de dire qui subit pas la position
en faisant petit rock et un truc où tu
es mal stratégiquement il fait un truc
un peu plus un peu plus double tranchant
foufou
voilà je pense que voilà c'est son
premier bon coup de la
partie mais c'est bien déjà donc il est
rentré dans sa partie
quoi et si je fais stat tu
peux il est sur grand
rock je faire faire tour8
pourquoi pas bien sûr S h41 ou je sais
pas quoiame elle va plutôt par là-bas
donc j'ai pas envie
deutre un J fera B5 on ve lui donner un
pion et moi je feris plutôt ça
perso tu
peux couput fait petit rock oui mais ça
change pas la Danne du coup je fais
tour8 moi jeis plus
ça tout
bien je trouve qu'elle va être mal
placée
pe-être sur grand enfin peut toujours
revenir
mais ouis moi ser ro
F7 on verra bien on verra pr que quie
G8
il pour peut-être avoir de pion de plus
quand même
ou faut pas se tromper à priori ça va
que FAO mais quand tu commences à donner
du
matérielgalou machin et ça
ok du dame 7 pas bête non
pluscord je suis d'accord ave 7 alors
l'ordi te réfute mais à cause d'un
truc un truc un peu chiant c'est ça mais
sinon c'est hyper
mal r c'est un grand mot ça prend pas
l'avantage cavalier pour le
coup
qui te
prends bon je dois dire que ça l'air
jouable he
ouais mais oui dame 7 c'est aussi malin
ouais je suis
d'accord
viar qu'est-ce qui s'est passé bah rien
de SP a plutôt mal joué l'ouverture ce
qui fait que une position très plaisante
assez
vite mais vient de jouer un coup
intéressant avec Dame G4 attaquer le
pion6 prépare grand rock donc veut
mettre un peu d'huile sur le feu donc il
cherche le combat lui on sait de toute
façon il doit jouer pour gagner la
partie nul lui sert pas à grand chose
donc il doit il doit
compliquer dans les autres parties il y
a vidit qui affronte prê de que c'est
très équilibré même assez égal une
finale et et Guiri et sipinko spinko a
sacrifié un pion dans
l'ouverture pour pour un bon
développement et et
ça ouais mais du coup je sais pas il a
l'air de jouer assez vite il de savoir à
peu près ce qu'il fait mais bon faut pas
se tromper c'est dur à dire donc
attention quand
même
pour session mix il y a aucune femme qui
joue parce qu'en fait comme il y a la
section féminine en même temps avec
quand même des prix assez conséquents
c'est plus intéressant financièrement
pour les femmes qui pourraient
participer à la séction mixte de
participer à la sélection féminine en
fait à la section féminine pardon donc
c'est une comme d'habitude en fait he
comme toujours c'est qu'une question
d'argent non mais c'est
oui non mais juste c'est toujours qu'un
question d'argent plus plus qualificatif
quoi c'est doublement de l'argent si tu
te qualifies pour les candidat oui mais
c'est encore une question tu peux faire
trucs c'est une question enfin pour
faire simple c'est une question d'argent
plus intéressant
financièrement c'est quand tu réfléchis
vraiment quasiment à n'importe quelle
question un peu comme ça pourquoi
quelqu'un fait si quelqu'un fait ça
c'est vraiment enfin je remarque de plus
en plus souvent à chaque fois que tu vas
répondre à pourquoi il il joue C joue ça
pourquoi Caren a joue si plus jou aux
échecs bah argent enfin ouais non mais
c'est tout le temps argent en
fait la S de PRAG est forte B joue pas
mal hein quoi 2440 par là 50
peut-être est-ce que ça conuit est ce
qu'on voit beaucoup moins les femmes
dans les échecs bah non parce qu'elles
joue leur féminin donc tu peux les
voir après après il y a le fameux débat
toujours est-ce que il faut qu'il a des
tournois féminins et est-ce que tout
doit va pas être mixte ou quoi c'est un
are débat après c'est unre débat et
toute façon c'est pas nous qui
organisons ou quoi mais chacun peut
penser comme il veut et
peut-être en tout cas c'est comme ça
quoi est-ce qu'on peut faire rock dam 6
ouais j'y pensais mais je crois que
c'est pas très rentable quoi parce qu'on
sit trouvé la case des 5
quoi
on dit déjà faut pas mettre les tour en
même temps alors d'un côté tu as raison
Jul 30 après là encore question d'argent
malheureusement c'est encore là que le
baabess c'est que c'est tellement cher à
organiser et ça rapporte tellement rien
que je pense que c'est plus simple de
grouper les deux
tournois donc je pense que la raison euh
c'est toujours la même c'est toujours la
même ouais
il a choisi d'AM F6 du coup et
[Musique]
euh et sinon non hein ce qualifi au
candidat ça fait pas une norme de GM ça
fait une norme de GM si tu fais une
norme de GM c'est tout donc tu peux
faire les de en même temps si tu
affrontes suffisamment de grand-mre tu
fais une performance à plus de 2600 et
cetera et cetera visuellement tu te
qualifies euh non
normalement tu pourrais arriver mais ah
non je parle de féminin mais
euh mais normalement oui ça devrait le
faire parce qu'il y a quand même pas mal
de joueures qui sont grand maîtres dans
le tournoi donc normalement tu auras ton
quota et la moyenne ho et les
nationalités et tout quoi al peut-être
qu'il veut suivre la ligne de l'ordi
grand rock
H5 damage TR petit rock alors pourquoi
est-ce que ce H5 intercalé pour pouvoir
avoir du dame pr F2
ouis
ouais ça c'est dur enfin ais mais c'est
nak non mais
oui c'est Naka après hein king is
we c'est très très dur mais c'est
Naka
mimounette attention il y a le pion e 6
sans prise d prchque r don quand tu
prends E3 il aurait pas repris F pr il
aurait d'abord fait d' PR6 on avait
montré la variante ah non il est très
très bien
laanaka je pense qu'il va qu'il va
passer
hein B écoute favoris avant et c'est pas
l'ouverture qui nous faire changer
d'avis non mais là je pense que le début
de du truc il est très bien parce que
vidit près de que c'est plutôt enfin ça
se dirige vers la nulle c'est un grand
mot he ça joue
encore et euh et Giri et cpienko bon
Guiri il a quand même quelques chance
donc pour le moment ça part très bien la
partie d'aliera ça l'air un peu le bxon
j'ai l'impression que son adversaire
connaît bien qu' aime bien le
[Musique]
boxon carwana keer ça sent
être anecdotique finalement oui là je
crois que ça va pas avoir
d'impact TR bizarre que vidit soit pas
le bordel B le truc c'est que vidit il
peut aussi passer avec une n alors bon
oui mais en fait ça c'est vite dirigé
dans le néant quoi euh mais ouais mais
en plus il connaî il connaî Guiry il
voit qu'il joue le gain enfin il reste
un peu dans un entre deux et il a
peut-être raison enfin nul peut quand
même le
qualifier donc l'un dans l'autre Fab
mais bon il peut quand même gagner la
partie hein enfin il a pas abdiqué
complètement les ambitions mais c'est
vrai que ça il tout d'un coup prendre
masse de risque je sais pas trop
comment et là pour le moment bah
[Musique]
il il est là
quoi tant mieux
hein tant mieux pour
nous mais je pense vraiment que Naka va
juste gagner en fait et mettre tout le
monde
d'accord
mais d'accord de notre point de vue
c'est que s'il gagne il peut pas être
rattrapé il peut rrapé par spinko mais
çaen fera qu'un çaen fera pas deux
oui ça Chang rien pour
nous Toronto ça do être joli ouais
sûrement que c'est très sympa mais non
nous on est on y va pas on n jamais trop
convé à ces trucs mais on commenttera
depuis ici comme comme
toujours
vous pr TR ouais mais c'est au blanc de
jouer c'est pas au noir donc oui si
c'est au noir de jouer ils vont faire F
3 et faire pr c de on imagine que va
trouver un coup qui va éviter tout ça
d'arriver du style
grand en tout cas il est vraiment côté
r demande si laante kashnikov est une
vente
risquée non pas particulièrement c'est
ça va c'est solide quoi enfin c'est ça
joue en plus tu peux dicter le jeu que
tu veux avec ton choix de variante donc
non c'est une bonne c'est une bonne
ligne j'aurais peut-être me mettre à la
jouer moi la calache le problème he
juste comme ça c'est pas la calach en
soi c'est que faut être après sur tout
les autres trucs genre TR fou B5 que qui
arrivve au moins aussi souvent que 3 D4
tu as tris k C3 tu as les alapin tu as
les cennes fermé donc ça demande quand
enfin c'est pas tu joues la cenne que tu
es sûr tu vas jouer la calchee loin de
là d'ailleurs mais mais en
soit la plupart des mecs ils ouvrent pas
en fait non moins d'un sur de mais
pourquoi
pleutre je sais pas Mo enfin mais tu es
pas très énervé quand tu cilien du coup
que les mecsouvr pas bah peu importe
enfin après moimême je l'ouvre pas trop
quoi donc tu vois je vais pas reprocher
aux autres mais tu te dis pas que tu es
pleutre quand tu joues pas des4 au 3e
fous en B5 je suis très heureux oui mais
tu est-ce que est-ce que au moment où tu
te fais fous B5 tu te dis je suis quand
même assez pleutre ou même pas non non
je suis très heureux mais en fait ce qui
est con pour moi c'est que moi je joue
ça depuis le début des années 2000 quoi
et qu'à l'époque c'était pas la mode
c'était une petite ligne et je faisais
ça justement pour pour jouer aux échec
ave mes petits plans un peu je suivais
les parties de rubski époque bon mais
c'est devenu main trop main quoi enfin
c'est encore plus théorique que l'autre
quasiment maintenant quoi donc euh bah
dommage tuas un peu le suum quand même
quoi
ouais je une verture avec les noir qui
donne du jeu quien sur le C ah non mais
c'est pour le mec joue laassenne fermée
ça m'intéresse absolument pas c'est
infernal non mais ça joue
enfin mais juste je veux dire déjà à
quelâge ça demande du boulot pour la
jouer
mais mais il faut faut être prêt sur
tout le reste
quoi moins la structure tu forces ta STR
bah oui laand tu forces ta structure tu
forces complètement la la structure
absolument rien à faire
ou même jou 4 C5 C4 ouais B c'est
trop trop des4 ça je fais
pas mais du coup moi je ferais E5
làdessus non mais je je fais genre k C6
G6 fou
g7e le trou
quoi d que serait tellement bien si
tuéta obligé de jouer des positions un
peu ouvertes tout le
temps B moi je suis pour le random chess
hein
de toute façon
mais bon il y a pas de tournoi quasiment
jamais tout le monde s'en fout donc
quand il des tourn je me suis fait
déglinguer
quoi bah l'avenir des échecs ou pas B
ch moi j'aime bien il y a pas mal de
joueurs qui aiment bien mais il y a trop
peu de tournois et et trop peu de gens
intéressés on fera un sondage dans le
chat ça inéresserait pas grand monde
donc finalement je crois enfin je crois
pas qu'il aura un grand avenir à ce jeu
bizarrement le jeu que les gens ont bien
kiffé pour y avoir un petit peu jouer
c'est le King of the hill tu mon leur
mieux ouais les gens ont pas mal kiffé
Viscom je crois qu'ils m'ont dit que
c'était la variante que les gens
préférent de tous ah les stats ok mais
c'est vrai que c'est l'avantage du King
of the hill c'est que ça ressemble
vraiment aux échecs oui oui mais avec la
règle en plus oui mais elle change pas
mal de trucs bah
oui tu dis que je gamb peut-être pas con
quoi qui mon de et
tout Oui random ch c'est 960 c'est
pareil c'est juste de appellations de la
même
chose meilleur joueur supposé de 960 je
crois que est vraiment fort
ouais ils sont pas
mal joue bien été champion du monde
cette année bah c'est toujours les mêmes
en fait j'imagine que Magnus c'est quand
même pas trop nul et cetera
mais mais ok c'est plus cool quand tu es
pseudo retraité que tu as pas envie de
faire de l'ordi toute la journée à
regarder ses variantes
quoi bag c'est cool aussi ouais moi
j'avais le l'intention je sais pas si ça
se fera les amis mais de faire un
championnat de France de bugous l'an
prochain par équipe par équipe de de
ouais forcément ouais mais tu sais tu as
la version toujours 1 V1 c'est crazy
house 11 ouis non non je vais faire le
buous en 2
V2 le crazyous c'est pas mal aussi en
fait
hein euh Buga c'est Blitz 4 en fait je
sais pas si vous avez déjà entendu c'est
tu joues par équipe de de genre je suis
avec Kev allez j'ai les Noirs il a les
blancs on joue contre de mecs bah viceva
et en fait dès que je prends une pièce à
mon adversaire ou que Kev prend je la
file à mon partenaire donc si j'ai
bouffé un pion blanc à mon adversaire k
un pion blanc il peut le poser sur lesqu
c'est son coup donc qui peut bah au de
jouer un coup avec ses pièces qu'il a
déjà par rachuter la pièce en plus bam
et et voilà donc euh donc intéressant
important les blancs important
l'initiative à ce jeu parce que bah tu
peux faire des combos attaquer tout d'un
coup avec toutes tes pièces qui
débarquent euh peut-être ton partenaire
a absolument besoin d'une pièce dans sa
position bah faut être prêt à sacrifier
pour l'autre ou quoi donc il la pose où
ve oua en gros il a pose où il veux en
tu ASO te prendre avec hein tu peux dire
ah tiens j'ai un pion je la mets à la
place de ta dame mais tu peux le poser
faire une fourchette avec oui ou tu peux
mettre mettre échec ou je pense c'est
une bonne idée he ce championnat de
France ouais ouais mais après faut
faudrait qu'on le fasse sur ordi parce
que arbitré c'est unarbitrable mais bon
on a le lieu pour le faire on a tout ce
qu'il faut en fait ouais il manque que
l'argent comme ouais c'est fou en fait
ch tu au même au même problème et le
crisous c'est le même jeu mais en 1 V1
c'est quand tu bouffes un truc à ton
adversaire après tu peux le poser toi
genre tuas les Noirs tu il fait 4 D5 il
fait pion prend D5 tu fais dame prend
bah le coup d'après tu peux poser un
pion quoi parce que tu l'as mangé euh
donc
voilà mais oui c'est obligé de le faire
sur ordi ça sinon c'est impossible à
arbitrer sauf peut-être la finale où tu
peux mettre deux échiquers et essayer
mais à fa vraiment que des pendules
partent en même temps que
ouais jogi je extrêmement sous côté
alors je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
avec toi du du dol pro euh en Japon
c'est hyper populaire he ça passe même à
la télé c'est sous côté chez nous quoi
c'est sous côté chez nous ouais à cause
des échecs
d'ailleurs mais c'est vrai qu'en as dit
ils ont leur version des échecs nul he
Maxime c'était prévisible et
prévu vu l'ouverture par fallit
peut-être çait peut-être jouer mais en
fait pas tant que
ça en Europe j'entends oui oui en
Occident mais c'est à cause des échecs
hein classiques mais moi avir jouer un
peu au Shogi je pense que j'aurais
préféré le shogi c'est tactique plus
marrant
ouais mais bon après je te dis ça mais
c'est pas dit c'est juste
visuellement
SP pas aussiersa pe refuser ton CP tu
dois accepter sa deuxième proposition
ouais ref ouais mais tu fa toutes les
versions que tu veux enfin tu peux te
marer avec tout les échecs marseillais
les machin dame cacher hein ouais mais
mais après c'est marant 5 minutes j'ai
envie de dire ça va pas devenir un jeu
tellement
populaire les échecs c'est juste bien en
soi quoi je pense que 960 est bien en
soi aussi quoi mais
l'idée d'utiliser les pièces de mon
adversaire c'est triste je trouve ça
donne l'impression que l'armée ennemi
trahit son roi ouais comme souvent quand
il y a des guerres en fait et des
alliances c'est quoi le jeu mais il aime
pas le BIT SAAC qu' a l'impression que
tu tu trahis ton ton ton équipe quoi tu
vas jouer avec les autres comment ça bah
tuou bah tu manges une pièce et du coup
genre tu as l'armée de tes ennemis qui
vientn te rejoindre mais ouais c'est
peut-être même plus réaliste en
réalité te trahissait quoi mais bon moi
de toute façon je vois pas trop les
échecs comme une guerre en fait c'est
juste un jeu c'est un jeu de plateau
quoi ouais c'est un jeu de plateau
quoi
ah le shogi palbit 4 ouais c'est un jeu
de plateau
quoi tout est des jeux de plateau
hein la dame cachée s'entraîne à la
marlouterie c'est beau beau jeu la dame
cachée jeu très difficile hein
marrant une part de bluff et
tout
l'ordi du damage 6 mais bon la position
est belle damage 6 ça paraît très
logique he bah ouais tu te décales
tuataques le truc tu t'enlève de ça et
si te fait tour un pour protéger tu
bouffes et tu lui bouffes ces deux quoi
t H3 dame F6 tu reviens tu menac fais
tour F3 tu fais dame 7 et tu vas revenir
vers D4 et c'est gagnant donc dam H6 ça
crée une grosse menace quand même prends
il va te faire dame de et tu peux
revenir ici ici enfin non c'est pénible
pour les blancs il est sur pr des 6 qui
des4 il y a ces deux qui sautent quand
même mais ça se passe très bien genre de
partie que j'aimerais bien jouer moi
avec les
noirs câge de rêve non mais c'est
marrant par en fait me est 2700 et
quelques et j'ai juste jamais personne
qui me joue aussi mal quoi mais même mon
blit sur Internet quoi
c'est ouais mais c'est bizarre des fois
les
échecs visite ça pas bouger gu ça pas
bouger fou
juste il l'air pas malin nul quoi ouais
ça jou vite en face un pion de plus
quand même donc non pas encore pas
encore j'arrive pas à
compter je pens qu' de plus compé si
pour les blancs il est temps que le T
s'arrête mais oui tu vas faire
G3 tu tapes partout en fait c'est sympa
pour
pour ça le met bien de gagner pour
redonne des
points donc écoute on verra bien ce qu'
V en être
il y a peut-être la peur du nom le fait
de jou camé Magnus Carlsen peut
perturber des gens plus que Fabien
libizevski je suis pas sûr hein
ouais mais c'est pas bon signe quand
quand tu es supposé être un un futur
grand du jeu ou tu as des ambitions de
de faire si c'est ça le problème après
tu peux rater parce que tu rates hein
mais si c'est juste la peur
euh ça sent pas bon pour sa carrière
quoi il nous fait pas vibrer dans cette
partie
non pas trop pas du tout fait pas vibrer
parce qu'il vibre pas
quoi
nakak qui prend son temps il a raison
hein
ouais et donc la niche qui a piqué le
deuxième
pion falloir être un peu
précis côté sipeno pour l'instant c'est
bien joué he l'ordi a l'air de de dire
que c'est très correct ce qu'il fait
mais tour C8 tour à 7 qui des enfin mais
je oui en fait soit il connaî à peu près
les TH et et il sait mais euh d'aller
là-dedans c'est pas évident de bien
juger quoi
F2 par que ça j' l'impression je ressors
moi
tour1 tour 7 mais bon c'est V je me fais
bouffer les pions les un après les
autres ou c'est ça je
pense tu vas repèdre tes pions ouais
genre je fais ro F1 il a to reprends le
de ouais et tu reprends A2 je refais F2
je me fais échanger et puis tu gardes ta
tour ça donc bah peut-être ça faire une
nulle assez insipide comme ça mais bonne
prépa de de cpenko et donc si si Penko
fait nul V doit Absolum gag doit
absolument gagner parce que Naka perdra
pas
ou ça pe être la chance de PRK est-ce
que pr que peut finir devant les cpenko
je pense 26 86 mais il est déjà devant
il est déjà devant ouais donc ah oui
mais et sipenko mais il ferait que nul
et l'autre gagne donc il manque encore
ah
il sera à tous les de ouais mais non il
serait quand même devant pr alors
attends pr que il joue en combien bah
c'est 27 pas débile quoi7 15 y a 35
points d'écart 37 pointcart dilué sur
sur pas mal de rondes ça a dû être
calculé mais ouais je
pense que 4 points de per de
di ouais 37 points divis par 11 ouais au
point près ça devrait le faire c'est
peut-être que diviser par 10 parce que
tu enlèves le plus nul ouais
passer de
justesse mais si on jou l'un contre
l'autreêre dans le cas complètement
débile
ouais ils ont joué l'un contre l'autre
donc dans le cas déb en fait si tu annul
leur partie l'un contre l'autre c'est
qui passe c'est be ce serait le cas sûr
ont que 30 avoir un point de
différence mais écoute on mais je pense
pas gagner
mais on souffle que Jo gagn le
tournoi il gagne berc c'est
fait pas un très bon match de Dimitrov
aujourd'hui
inoxidable parce que tu fais encore des
tournois régulièrement tu as des élèves
on s là que tu
bah je fais plus trop de tournois j'en
ai fait quand même deux cet été j'ai
joué la Coupe d'urope des Clubs le mois
dernier donc je je suis pas encore
retraité complètement mais bon à moitié
quoi et sinon ouais je donne quand même
toujours un peu des cours
euh on publie des trucs avec Kev on fait
des livres euh on fait les vidéos euh
j'ai tourné des des vidéos bah pour les
DVD chez chessbas ou quoi je je fais des
stages avec Mazo aussi jeen referai avec
Kev quand on pourra refaire donc voilà
c'est plutôt ça et la prochaine actu ben
je vais euh travailler pour l'équipe de
France là pour le Championnat d'Europe
comme comme second an à distance donc
voilà c'est ça l'ctue sinon rien
de rien de bien foufou je vais rejoint
tourno la fin du mois mais compte pas
pour le lot c'est plus un tourno de
vacances en Irlande et voilà donc pas de
grande actu non plus
hein tuas Corneto en Irlande ouais AA
Mao il y aura Mao aussi la fine
équipe pas de stage prévu l'été prochain
alors bah moi j'en ai un de prévu avec
Seb Maé Santa suousanna comme chaque
année et avec Kev on sait pas mais mais
peut-être enfin on vous dit pas non mais
il faut qu'on
trouve qu'on puisse le faire que les
dates coïncident on dit pas ça va ouais
voilà donc dame 7 si jamais on vous dira
quoi il a joué d'AM donc il défend des6
et il se libère la colonef voilà
j'habite où j'habite à côté de SAÉ quoi
c'est moins fort quand même que damage 6
ouais mais tout aussi solide
mais je suis quand même encore un peu
inquiet hein qui est nul ici nul ici
pienko et victoire de visite ou euh prê
que
hein serait cataclysmique là cette
séance qualificative au candidat côté
français on a'urait même pas menacé de
se qualifier quoi ce qui est quand même
assez incroyable G on a même pas menacé
jusqu'à maintenant en fait non en fait
on espère les qure figures favorables
quoi ouais bah là c'est juste qu'on
espère le truc pour menacer mais en fait
sinon j'ai envie de dire on aura même
pas menacer quoi mais par méga chance
par méga chance parce que Carana s'est
déjà qualifié par le circuit normal Naka
serait qualif par le circuit normal Nebo
serait qualifié par le circuit normal et
Ding aussi quoi enfin tous les mecs
devant ah bah il se trouve qu'ils ont
bien joué les tour qualificatifs qui se
sont qualifiés pour ça que si en fait
Naka se qualifie pas comme ça on aura
même pas menacé
ouais
même si prenait 15 points je crois qu'il
a trop de retard sur les car enfin mais
de toute façon
ilarou il va finir dans les deux
premiers ici je pense donc Figur non il
y a il y a un cas de figure on sa et
puis il peut gaffer et puis il peut se
passer des choses mais vu les
positions pour le moment on est pas mal
mais non mais a 25 points 25 points
d'écart pas 15 hein ouais entre ikaro et
c'est quand Mme j'aurais dit bon il y a
une petite chance mais 25 ça paraî quand
même
dur 15 c'est par possible faudit
terminer la T avec 8 sur 9
ouais non mais genre oui siarou fait nul
et termine 3è du
tournoi ouais il y a un espoir
mathématique mais ah non mais après il a
l'esoir de des agents de joueur et puis
tu as aussi le cas de figure qui un mec
joue pas finalement les candidats et qui
je sais pas quoi é
repêché mais bon la calife en bonnet du
forme c'est
fini mais moi je dis il y a encore les
agents de
joueur il y a toi quoi il y a moi il y a
moi l'agent de joueur qui trucque tout
quoi et pourquoi ça existe pas les
agents de joueurs mais ça existe un peu
oui mais il truc que rien je crois pas
en tout cas ils se vendent pas parce
sinon mais ils font quoi en fait ces AG
joueurs là actuellement rien il te il te
il te trouve des clubs où tu prends de
la caillass dans les clubs il prennent
un pourcentage et peut-être il trouve
des il trouvve des temp à fermer il y a
qui en agent de joueur mais j'en connais
pas trop mais mais moi moi personne s
jamais proposé d'être mon agent je veux
dire mais moi je peux pas devenir je
peux pas essayer de si si tu fais tu
fais tu fais caber industrie et tu c pas
que c'est une idée de génie ça ça me
chauffe la truc d'agent de joueur je
suis agent de joueur et en fait c'est
que pour truquer les tournois en fait
des joueurs dans plusieurs clubs et
appeler
quoi mais ça ça doit se faire en en fait
le truc c'est que soit il te faut des
joueurs très forts euh qui cherchent des
forts tournois à être invités ou quoi ou
des mecs un peu à l'agonie euh qui suent
et qui veulent jouer dans des clubs en
France ou prendre de la petite caillass
quoi des cailloux mais je peux appeler
cabéev sport quoi
ouais en prison et j'ai truqué les
matchs de Top
14 liste de clients pour pour agent de
joueur c'est ça tu veux pas qu'on se
lance là-dedans big ver chess c'est
Étienne en fait big ver chess h je pense
qu'il veut bien se lancer aussi dans le
délire des agents joueurs je pense qu'il
est très très chaud
non il connait plein d'organisateurs de
tournois oui il va être bien quoi non
mais en fait si
tu si tu connais le truc enfin ça existe
un peu c'est pas trop répondu mais ça
peut être utile après il y a
pas c'est moins important que dans le
foot quoi on va dire
mais il peut tuis je pense je pense
qu'il sait réduire les cûts pas très bon
commercialement mais il peut bien nous
réduire les coups va PIR bien négocier
quand même
avec avec des clubs machin allez tour 10
parties pay 9
ouais vas-y lance le le cabin
quoi mais nous on serait capable de tout
on changerait la phase des échecs en
fait a que des Français au
candidat bah après s'il a d'autres
nationalités qui pay
plus
ah tapis avec dans le r principal
ouis la
pieuvre je pense qu'on pratiquera
lomerta on sait jamais rien on est de
rien en fait on est déjà agent jur
mais déjà fa déjà appel ce matin
Mach PA est moi je peuqu deire
ça pe inquiétude parce que comm à
prendre peu les
devant
ouais des petits de enfin en fait le
truc c'est que le truc c'est que j'ai
pas la finesse pour ces positions je les
joue avec aucune des deux couleurs mais
quand je vois ça
j'ai on va voir on verra au retour de la
pause mesdames et messieurs on va faire
une petite respiration de 17h et on vous
rejoin dans une dizaine de minutes allez
à tout de
suite
[Musique]
he
mesdames et messieurs n'ayez pas peur si
vous avez peur d'avoir raté quelque
chose P la pause il ne s'est rien passé
donc au moins c'est c'est bien on
revient là où on en était après ce dame
2 et ikarou qui a peut-être pas choisi
la manière la plus forte de faire
fructifier son avantage Fab ouais après
bon si s'il s'en fiche et que nul juste
lui suffit il peut un peu jouer ce qu'il
a envie de jouer et tout va bien c'est
vrai que le damage 6 ça va l'air pas mal
mais ça
écoute je sais pas j'ai l'imession pe
jouer une multitude de coups
tout va
bien côté vidit il y a eu du gessco pour
prê que mais c'est pas vraiment un coup
agressif c'est plus qui se prend de
l'espace ouais
et 4 jouer donc peut-être qu'il veut
supprimer ce k C6 pourir fou B4 un jour
et écoute je sais pas
enfin ça va ça va et si pian on est
toujours à la même position à laquelle
on était faut qu'il trouve les coups
précis pour faire nul
ala écoute il a quand même ce cette
position un peu plus agréable après elle
est loin d'être gagnée et caroana keimer
keer qui donne tout et Fabiano qui
semble un peu un peu plus en retrait de
depuis depuis 2 jours peut-être érinté
de de de ces de ces tournois qui qui
s'enchaînent ça peut mais euh il joue
encore une partie de combat
aujourd'hui en tout cas on avance petit
à petit dans dans cette journée
ultime de ce grand
Suisse
mais ouais en fait j'ai du mal à trouver
les problèmes pour
Naka pas problme juste que c'est
peutêtre pas facile de gagner non ça
c'est jamais facile mais en gros lui son
objectif c'est juste de pas perdre quoi
et et ça va
quoi une fo4 pour mettre la pression sur
tu te décalerais un peu puis il y a pas
réellement de pression il fait C6 j'aime
bien le coup pour qu'
D4 mais pourquoi
pas pour améliorer ce cheval
ouais non F H4 c'est pas pas terrible
terrible tu perdrais pas avec ton coup
hein mais ça pas l'air très très
inspiré son coup de retour du cavalier
bah franchement pourquoi pas il pense
qu'il a fait son son
taf en B4 et c'était le cas il a mis la
pression sur C2 il a contrôlé la case D5
quand il fallait et cetera et là
maintenant tout ça c'est fait et que
c'est couvert et ben il revient se
mettre sur une case plus centrale plus
sympa est-ce quetien est qualifié alors
non il a fait nul aujourd'hui il termine
avec 7 points je crois 6 et demi 6 et
demi peut-être ouais 6 et demi qui un
excellent un excellent score bien
évidemment mais la bataille pour la
Calif va jouer à voire même points et
demi sement mais ouais euh non ouais pas
de qualification mais bon quoi 10 12
points Lau peut-être donc c'est c'est un
très bon tournoi quoi excellent même
excellent mon
Fab très très beau tournoi de Baki après
voilà la
Calif peut-être ça va juste tout
simplifier hein tu fais c
des4 qu'il a envie d' faire quali E2 tu
prends E3 tu prends E2 tu prends
F1 puis tu tu fais rien et puis tu mets
une tour en C6 tu as besoin un jour de
défendre D6 et puis c'est tout quoi puis
tu fais nul ouais ouais peut-être
hein peut-être bien mon Fab
euh ben écoutez pourentage de chance que
Nasfi grâce au grand Suisse il est assez
élevé je pense il est pas à l'abri d'une
nouelle surprise si tout se passe mal
mais bon il aura encore le hlo derrière
donc non mais lui en fait il est
tranquille pour le candidat mais je veux
dire pour ça qualifieci en gros faut que
vidit gagne
ou peut-être près de enfin faut qu'il a
un vainqueur et que Guiry
batenko non c'est l'inverse c'est
l'inverse ne perd pas contre Guiri pour
qu'il se qualifie pas il faut que ipenko
fasse nul ou gagne contre Guiri et qui a
un vainqueur dans la partie vidite prê
que et voilà pour l'instant vis pr que
c'est calme mais bon vu que les deux
peut-être comprennent sils vont faire un
truc à un moment ça peut ça peut
s'animer alors que Bert qui a reçu le
livre 365 jours pour gagner aux échecs
c'est top bah
écoute recommande-le à tes amis s'il te
plaît merci bien
oui si tu veux ceux qui l'ont si vous
vouz faire découvrir à votre entourage à
votre club à vos amis je sais pas à
votre famille à vos
conjoints Mog demande pour qu'on est bon
on est pour
euh
ouais on peut être pour Guiry ça
assurerait le truc et sinon tu peux être
pour nul entre visite et et prê de C
voilà il y a pas besoin des deux en même
temps mais bon le mieux c'est juste
d'être
pour c'est fini ouais moi tu cétait pour
quelque chose que V en fait tu es pour
la nul donc tu sais pas trop pourquoi tu
es tu es pour qu'il a pas de gaffe mais
bon tu es pas pour que les mecs jou des
trop bon coup non plus
enfin les pièceséchang ouais tu pour
qu'il fasse de la merde en fait comme
d'hab mais tu es jamais à
l'abri ah oui
Micha ne prête demandle de l'acheter
évidemment surtout pas le prêter fais
voir il se vend pas mal ou pas sur
Amazon j'ai pas les chiffres mais je
regarder mais je crois pas non il je
pense je pas trop je crois que les gens
achètent pas forcément sur
Amazon je peux trouver je pense mais je
vais l'avoir là voilà il est là
non si il se bat il se bat ouais il se
bat il se bat ouais il est là il
commentaire commentaire ouis
bravo et le cahier
d'entraînement il se bat pas mal he il
se bat même plus non ouais il se bat
bien ouais des devoir de vacances
stimulant on attend la suite pour l'été
prochain pour jouer aux échecs bravo
blitstam sont heureux tout niveau bien
occupé mon fils et son père une femme
qui doit être très
heureuse aller faire les exercices les
amusezv le cahier rouge et laissez-moi
tranquille il gagné aux
échecs il se bat très bien aussi he il
se bat aussi ou mais j'ens sont aussi PL
de les Chiki avec commentaire à chaque
étape très bien très confible même pour
un début comme moi
incroyable validé le meilleur livre
éducatif pour débuter aux échecs très
bien fait parfait pour débutant
amateur he ou
quoi
sur le Pass Culture je crois qu'il y en
a quelquesuns qui sont sur le Pass
Culture ça je sais pas moi et pour 1700
chzcom bah tu peux prendre progresser
aux échecs le cahier d'entraînement et
les 365 jours juste le premier faut pas
le prendre gagner aux échecs 1700 tu es
trop
fort dédicace possible en passant par
Baky bah actuellement non Baky là il est
en en déplacement donc c'est pas pas
toujours faisable en fait c'est dédicace
ça prend quand même beaucoup de temps
que ce soit à nous à Baki ou quoi donc
on les fait parfois en les regroupant
mais pas pas à n'importe quel
moment trop
dur j'achète tous tes livres maintenant
je suis 2000 tu imagines quand on va
sortir encore d'autres livres tu vas
pouvoir progresser à fond hein ilô
passer devant moi
ouais ben ça fait la varante que tu as
dit les qu qui deux et j'imagine cétait
venu en
des4 tu vas les changer celui-là et tu
dégommes tout quoi si tu et tu peux
prendre ici en premier ouis F et prendre
en C2 prendre tu prends ici
ouais bon le cavalier ressort pas ok
j'ai
compris dangereux
ouais bon c'est calcule tout et qu'il
peut il peut mais sinon
tu liqu tout lesquel reste intéressant
bah le cahier d'entraînement le progress
aux échec et le 365 jours où tu vas
quand même apprendre des des anecdotes
sur les échecs donc en fait à peu près
pareil
après bon le cahier tu vas quand même en
trouver pas mal assez facilement quoi
oui mais bon mais après il a des côtés
intéressants mais je te le mets en
numéro 3 quoi
ouais mais bon il coûte que 10 balles
oui non mais Mo moi je serais content
que tu le prennes moi j'aurais pris un
mais mais je réponds honnêtement mais il
est pas inintéressant non pluso enfin
bah non mais bon tu fais des exercices
puis bon tu as les mots mêlés enfin tu
as d'autres trucs à résoudre quoi ouais
rien que le mot mêlé tout seul quoi va
l'achat du livre en fait entourer les
mots machin enfin c'est bien
quoi non mais gen je l'ai
[Musique]
fait c'est intéressant les mots mêlés
non mais tous les petits quiz ou quoi je
trouve c'est pas mal aussi bah tu as les
quiz tuas les by il a pas répondu à tous
les quiz il en a raté un ou deux
hein
un peu décevant la partie du carou quand
même avoir fait le damage 6 et tout pour
jouer le gain bon je crois qu'il s'en
fout
complètement après on vérifier à quel
point c'était si fort çait une bonne
tête mais peut-être que c'était pas
si ça joue pas tropin non un peu comme
tous les jours au final
Fab un peu comme tous les jours ce t qu'
aura pas intéresser les fou on en
discute là pendant la pause même en
anglais il y a très peu de spectateurs
j'ai jamais vu aussi peu de spectateurs
en fait ouais mais j'ai pas compris la
Fed qui disait qu' attendit des millions
de spectateurs enfin de de
viewers on est
mon maisim ils sont 6000 le dernier jour
quoi donc pour aller faire des millions
faut faut y aller non mais 6000 le
dernier jour pour un tournoi
qualificatif au candidat avec ikarou qui
joue la première place j'ai halluciné en
fait h c'est genre j'ai jamais vu aussi
peu pour un tournoi d'échec
dans le cycle championnat du monde avec
un enfin avec un joueur américain qui
suit les agents de spectateur son existé
aussi ouais non mais V enfin réellement
là je pour le coup je trollle pas vous
savez que j'aime bien troller avoir du
second degré mais là franchement ça m'a
choqué à quel
point quel point il y a personne ouais
franchement c'est c'est choquant mais
j'ai remarqué que sur les les échecs ça
a beaucoup baissé là depuis quelques
semaines quelques mois mais je
m'attendais pas à ce point là en fait il
y a un jeu qui pris l'ascendant dessus
ou c'est juste c'est la mode c'est comme
ça il a un peu les Worlds League of
Legends en ce moment mais non c'est pas
ça qui a c'est arrivé qu'il y a eu
d'autres événements d'échec qui tombent
pendant des gros événements League of
Legends non non c'est juste que B tu
sais c'est ma théorie depuis longtemps
j'en parlais déjà en février 2021 donc
c'est pour te dire mais en fait à force
de faire des trucs inintéressants et
chiant et nul à regarder dégoû un peu tu
dégoûtes les gens et au bout d'un moment
en fait tu as des gens qui en fait tant
que ça hype un peu tu as eu un
renouvellement de l'audience donc ça se
voit pas trop en fait juste tu
progresses pas alors que tu devrais
progresser mais bon comme les gens ils
sont là oh on reste au même niveau c'est
très bien bon ils comprennent juste pas
que il font un roulement mais une fois
que bah tu as intéressé un pool
extrêmement important de gens et que tu
as plus personne à faire découvrir en
fait sur une génération euh bah ce qui
se passe c'est que tu as plus de
renouvellement et que le truc qui est
terrible quand quand ce truc arrive
c'est ce qui arriv c'est ce qui arrive
là pour les échecs mais ce qui est
vraiment terrible là-dedans c'est que du
coup après tu es catalogué comme chiant
ah oui c'est que les gens ont déjà
regardé
je ze
quois bah ils ont a priori très négatif
après et c'est très difficile le ouais
mais non ils ont changé des trucs c'est
redevenu bien h c'est nettement plus dur
et je pense que c'est pour ça qu'il y a
des il y a des vagues pour les échecs
tous les 20 ou 25 ans il y a un truc qui
hype je pense c'est pour ça ma théorie
déjà en 2021 les gens vieillis oublié
que bah en faitas une nouvelle
génération mais en fait tu as réussi à
dégoûter toute une génération et il faut
attendre que ce soit les gens qui ah ti
j'ai joué il y a 10 15 ans et je me
rappelais plus faut le temps
d'oublier on nous a dit qu'il y avait
une gaffe alors je sais pas ce que c'est
gaffe c'est juste l'ordi qui vous dit
que c'est un coup douteux ou quoi mais
c'était pas l'histoire du Tour C8 mais
évident il a fait tour D4 je vire que si
le truc c'est ro f2ends F4 parce que ça
a l'air d'être l'idée et tu fais fou ENF
ça je veux bien comprendre ton petit P
de plus voilào tu as pas gagné avec les
blancs mais oui je veux bien comprendre
que ce soit un réel avantage parce que
tu as transformé ta majorité de pion
doublé en vraie
majorité donc écoute on va voir
peut-être peut-être bien pour nous vidit
il y a les C qui sont é changer la fait
son échec OK et euh il veut sortir sa
tour éventuellement bon c'est vrai que
oui enfin le R8 gêne un peu en ce sens
la liaison des tours et peut-être passer
par là-bas pourquoi
pas après peut-être qui B3 k A5 qui
C5 h je sais pas exactement on verra
fond de cours ikarou qui
réfléchit encore de la de chaîne
publique nouvelle fonction sur WhatsApp
mais ça je voulais le faire Fab c'est
quoi je connais pas en fait tu peux
faire une chaîne WhatsApp mais je trouve
parce qu'en fait Télégraph j'ai jamais
voulu le faire tellégram plutôt parce
que j'utilise pas mais WhatsApp tu
regarde mainant on peut faire des
chaînes d'accord et j'avais envie de le
faire mais bah je connais personne qui
le fait donc je sais pas mais bonne
suggestion Pascal Go j'ai pensé aussi
telgram en fait je connais personne qui
l'utilisent bon bon moi je suis dessus
mais je m'en sers pas trop donc je m'en
sers pas tellement donc WhatsApp comment
ça marche les chaînes fais voir ah je
sais pas mais j'ai vu que c'est arrivé
update il a un truc communi non starture
community moi j'ai mis WhatsApp en
anglais évidemment
donc pour reg des sports gratuit bah en
fait moi j'ai des comme j'ai pas mal de
potes encore en Russie je sais qu'
j'utilise un peu telgram mais c'est un
peu spécial
quoi tu peux créer une communauté ok get
started et puis pu c'est parti
euh bah après je sais pas à quoi ça sert
en fait je crois qu' peux faire des
trucs parler avec ta commu mais ça on
pourrait le faire c'est un peu mieux
discord en fait ça m'a vite saoulé
personnellement Pascal Go qui a fait qu'
fait de la pub pour sa chaîne publique
hein ça vient gratter le buzz côté
Pascal
Go c'est pas une journée faut dire aussi
ça c'est ces batailles
là décalé enfin pas en face à face c'est
c'est tout tout est bizarre là dans ce
grand Suisse je sais pas trop comment
dire il y a pas de ça a jamais pris
vraiment son son envolé lyrique ce
tournoi c'est lyrique mais ouais ça
s'env peut-être pas trop je sais pas
mais c'est ch toi tu aimes bien quand
c'est du 1 V1 à la fin et que tu
t'expliques ais pour moi les éche c'est
un sport de 11 tu t'expliques dans ma
ouais et là en fait tu joues contre des
c'est des gar par proxy quoi ouais
j'aime pas trop les gar par proxy quoias
des qui viennent des prê de que des
guéris so les vra qui se tapent dessus
quoi mais le non mais le tournoi il est
sympa c'est juste la cadence qui est
vraiment lente en fait après en soi ça
combat il y a des parties qui eu des
parties intéressantes c'est pas tout
n'est pas à jeter mais euh mais bon la
cadence quand même ah s avait bien un
truc à changer c'est la cadence ça on
peut
ouais parce que là en fait ça fait quand
même 2h dem0 que ça joue on n pas encore
vu grand-chose hein c'est tellement long
c'est hyper long zukart t fan il y a
même certaines choses que tu pourrais
faire deux voir trois voire six ou SEP
fois Fabien pendant une partie tu sais
et je n'étais vraiment pas en forme
forme je n'ai pu faire que qu FO
imagine 30 secondes par CS ça suffit bah
ça pourrait presque mais mais des fois
tu es content de réfléchir c'est pas le
problème mais et là ça c'est juste trop
quoi c'est trop tout le temps tu as le
rage au 40e tuas au 60e tuas le 1h40 au
lieu de 1h30 aussi ça fait quand même
une différence h non mais tout cumulé
quoi c'est ça si en avait que un bon 1
1h tu fais juste une non mais tu fais
une juste 1h 30 30 secondes 30 minutes
au 40e 10 minutes si tu veux au
60e déjà voilà ça enlèvera des trucs
mais bon bah c'est comme ça alors il a
pris en
le3 Lig full échange
ouais alors tour prend F1 ou peêre qu'
prend de bon je sais pas dans quel il
veut le faire il a pris d'abord
là-bas
ah il est parti il a gardé le cavalier
il a pas échangé alors pourquoi par
peut-être pas trop de cas il un peu peu
de ce B4 peut-être pourquoi pourquoi pas
j'ai envie de dire mais bon le pion C2
semiomestible parce après dame B3 le qu'
sortait pas alors peut-être on pourit
trouver un truc mais bon il était un peu
dangereux il dit qui que viit a trouvé
l'idée avec cavalier B3 ouais ouais
ouais non ça c'est logique en aller par
là-bas mais
après est-ce que surtour G5 il veut quo
en fait est-ce qu'on veut fou C5 ou C C5
je sais
pas fou C8 moi je
si ça passe je sais
pas et puis je sais pas
pour attention quand même pour
ikarou pour
plutôt en fait il a que il a tout à
perdre en fait
ouis mais lui il
contrôleien en fait il a rien à perdre
mais va faire nul il s'en fiche
il joue sa partie il essaie de presser
écoute on verra si ça passe ou pas il
est plutôt mieux mais
euh mais bon il vraiment rien de faire
c'est quand même assez solide en face la
position Fabi
OK
bon c'est peut-être plus que H coups
dans cette partie hein
peut-être et donc après on aura quoi
comme tour important on en a quelquesuns
parce qu'on va avoir le championnat
d'Europe par équipe la sfield rapide rap
blit la sfield normal la BUP 3 le
champion chest tour le championnat du
monde de Blitz championn du monde de
rapide il va y avoir encore plor de
tournoi pendant ces de mois à venir ça
va jamais s'arrêter je crois non ça
s'arrête
jamais enpri ce quiikaro il peut dire ou
B Haroun peut-être il va s'envoyer en
l'air c'est dur de s en l'air avec les
Blancs
en fait je veux dire Haroun sûrement il
espérait jouer dans cette partie et puis
bon ben il a raté l'ouverture et il a
rien pu obtenir m un moment bah tant pis
hein tu c'est comme ça j'ai envie de
dire tu peux pas tu peux
[Musique]
Pasin d'OPE ça commence samedi ou
dimanche le 11 je sais pasà c'est
l'arrivée des joueurs ou c'est la premi
non non je crois que le 11 c'est la
première ronde ça commence déjà samedi
prochain ah mais c'est sûr he euh
ouais je crois he il y a nef rondes il y
a une journé de repos au milieu r rond 2
R 3 R 4 r
58 39 ça finit à lundi par contre ouais
ouais c'est malin ça c'est très très
malin non mais tu rigoles on y avait pas
pensé non mais ils y pensent souvent eux
c'est pas du tout la première fois oui
gen c'est pas du hasard
c'est et c'est à quelle heure les ronde
je sais pas mais je dirais 14
15h qu'est-ce qu'on pense du EMI devenu
grand maître québécois Shun Rodrig le
mieux alors moi je le connais pas bien
mais déjà bah bravo à lui de d'avoir
complété ses normes et et de dépasser
les 2500
euh après comme je connais pas bien le
style de jeu ou quoi il a quel âge
d'ailleurs il est jeune on l' battu en
proess League mais genre jeune 15 ans
jeune 18 ans jeune 20 ans ouais il a
peut-être 19 20 ans il championnat du
monde junior je crois écoute c'est pas
mal hein il a 19 ans bah déjà il est
devenu grand plusutôt que moi euh après
c'est pas on va dire un temps prodige
par les temps qui court mais c'est déjà
bien et
euh je sais pas enfin ouais c'est bien
probablement Quand tu es dans ces ans de
passage tu peux espérer être un jouur à
plus de 2006 plus tard
quoi tu seras pas un joueur de l'élite
mondiale parler les top 10 et tout ça
mais pu faire une jolie petite carrière
et puis surtout en plus au Canada ils
ont pas tellement de de joueurs de ce
niveau- là il y a Eric en scè il y a eu
spragette avant mais tu vois j'en
connais pas des tonnes donc donc il peut
être numéro un Canadien et euh lu faire
une jolie petite carrière quoi gentiment
Pascal dit je ne comprends pas le
problème avec la cadence c'est pour le
spectateur que cela est gênant quand tu
es devant les chiqu je ne pense pas que
le temps passe comme nous le ressentons
alors déjà premièrement tu as beaucoup
de joueurs qui le disent aussi que la
avancé trop longue je pense à Magnus
Carlsen mvl qui en a aussi souvent parlé
je crois qu' Carana en a aussi parlé en
interview il y en a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de joueurs qui le pensent aussi
et puis aussi il faut voir qu'un tournoi
comme ça organisé ça coûte plusieurs
millions d'euros et un certains moment
ben tu dois aussi penser au au
spectateurs alors que ce soit une
question d'argent purure et dur c'est
déjà une chose mais même j'en parlais
hier quand quand tu fais quelque chose
sous activité humaine tu as envie de
faire plaisir à autru normalement c'est
c'est la nature humaine profonde enfin
il me semble en tout cas et donc quand
tu es joueur d'échec comme dans toute
autre activité ben c'est aussi important
de sentir que ce que tu fais ça a une
utilité que ça rend les autres heureux
aussi et que tu es pas juste quelqu'un
d'inutile assis devant un truc à pousser
du bois et juste à prendre de l'argent
pour enfin pour rien et tu as aussi
cette envie naturelle d'être humain de
d'avoir un partage une communion avec
d'autres et le fait que ça ça n'existe
pas je pense que c'est pas très
équilibrant mentalement et humainement
après c'est mon point de vue
mais après c'est vrai que quand tu joues
et quand tu regardes tu as pas la même
sensation de temps qui passe hein
mais mais ça reste l
quoi donc is moi je pense c'est quand
même important et équilibrant pour les
joueurs d'avoir cfin pour les gens en
général d'avoir l'impression de faire
quelque chose qui est une petite utilité
même si est microscopique et que tu
divertis un tout petit peu les gens tu
dis ah Mo je fais quand même quelque
chose d'intéressant après
ok para que ça se développe pas mal ch
au Québec en fait je suis jamais allé au
Canada au Québec ou quoi j'aimerais
bien mais ouais quand je voulais y aller
bah c'était l'année du covid donc j'ai
pas pu alors j'avais mes billets d'avion
j'avais tout quoi j'avais trouvé un
tournoi à jouer mais et euh et là je
sais que cette année en en en aût je
crois he ils vont organiser le
championnat de la Francophonie
normalement au Québec donc euh donc
ouais écoute si ça se développe très
bien on dit il y a des matchs de tennis
qui durent 5 6 7 he ben compare le
tennis et les échecs enfin je sais pas
au bout d'un moment c'est même pas que
c'est évident enfin c'est peut pas pas
avoir discussion enfin malheureusement
non c'est dur là c'est compliqué ouais
bon
malheureusement pourra pas rebondir
là-dessus
Fab non mais je sais pas en plus enfin
je veux bien rebondir mais c'est
que c'est chercher à mettre de la
mauvaise fois et tous les arguments que
tu vas pouvoir te raccrocher aux
branches mais le tennis déjà c'est rare
que ça
arrive ça peut arriver mais ok ça va
être une fois dans le tournoi parce que
ça s'est passé comme ça et que bon
mais là c'est tous les jours tout le
temps quoi enfin c'est déjà une énorme
différence
et et tu as pas le même spectacle de
toute façon même si le match dure
longtemps c'est même pas la durée c'est
même ce que tu vois quoi c'est que tu as
plein de points qui s'enchaînent des des
trucs des breaks tu as un spectacle tuas
là en fait tu vas attendre une
demi-heure dans cette position où tu as
pas un coup qui va se passer quoi donc
c'est même pas tu vois même pas la même
chose donc je sais pas c'est vraiment
pas pareil
ouais mais moi je suis pas contre qu'Age
de tennis dur longtemps enfin ah moi on
plus j'aime bien en fait c'est c'est
très bien enfin pour moi le maisner bah
très bien il resta dans la mémoire de
tout le monde et
il y a pas de souci hein bah en fait je
TR que ça arrive qu'une fois donc ça
rentre un peu dans l'utologie du truc
quoi c'est mais bon si tous les match à
chaque fois une demure entre deux points
tu regardes enfin le mec fait son
service pause bon il remet dehors il
sera assé pendant 30 minutes je pense
que tu regarderais enfin ça taurais pas
trop kiffé
quoi après c'est vous qui parlez
beaucoup de chaque à chaque stream a
paré de la durée des games c'est
redondant par contre on pourrait changer
plus souvent des chiquiers ah ben on
regarde quand même TR qu chiqu en ce
moment Alex Verson mais après comment te
dire c'est pas facile si tu enfin tu
vois nous enfin moi j'ai regardé je
crois que je vais passer 75 heures
devant le tournoi si à un moment donné
une fois par stream on en parle pendant
15 minutes je sais pas comment dire en
fait ça fait 1 heure sur 75 he c'est pas
beaucoup en fait c'est 1 ou 2 % du temps
après bah là on regarde les trois
parties qui sont importantes mais
qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'on te dise là
c'est égal il va normalement plus rien
se passer mais il peut se passer quelque
chose comme carwaner ils peut faire une
erreur mais ça il faut attendre les
coups ici la finale il va un peu la
presser mais c'est les joueurs qui ont
la vérité de la partie donc c'est à eux
de jouer les coups on peut pas les jouer
à leur place et Guiry ben on voit qu'il
va probablement avoir un pion de plus et
qu'il peut la presser donc en fait on
comprend tout ce qui se passe sur les
trois échiquet mais c'est les joueurs
qui ont la vérité de la partie c'est
comme si pendant un match de foot on
faisait sans AR arr sur image pendant 10
minutes pour te faire une palette de où
le joueur aurait pu théoriquement passer
et s'il avit passé le ballon peut-être
que le défenseur ait pu courir comme ça
mais du coup enfin ça a plus d'intérêt
si tapé la dame un peu plus comme ça
serait tombé 10 cm plus à gauche je sais
pas un moment donné il y a la vérité de
ce qui se passe et de la partie et de
les coups qui sont joués enfin les
positions sont égales mais c'est pas
parce qu'elles sont égal que ça va faire
nul c'est pas parce que les blancs sont
mieux qu'il vont gagner c'est les
joueurs qui ont la vérité des coups qui
vont s'échanger voilà il a joué dame C3
il a jou dam C3
mais dans la vérité de la partie
quoi
on peut pas on peut pas vraiment faire
plus quoi non et après pour les
échiquers bon B déjà c'est les seuls qui
compent pour pour la suite du tournoi
euh et la Calif mais en fait faut pas
oublier que beaucoup de gens dans le
public ont du mal à suivre plusieurs
parties en même temps déjà trois c'est
pas mal qure ouf mais tu en fais 10 et
tu zppes tout le temps tu perds tout le
monde enfin tout le monde non mais tu
vas perdre peut-être 80 0 % donc c'est
volontaire en fait de se limiter à
quelques parties après si on regardait
juste pour nous nous on regarderait le
grand truc comme ça et puis on enfin on
cliquerait vraiment comme ça en fait on
VO à droite à gauche si on regarde comme
nous on regarde on regarderait comme ça
on se barrerait 20 minutes on
reviendrait mais enà j'exagère un petit
peu mais en vrai on se scrollerait
vraiment comme ça puis un moment donné
on se dira bah tiens lui il a l'air
mieux on va regarder 2 secondes mais
pour nous on regarderait le tournoi
comme ça mais juste les gens sont pas en
capacité de le faire et c'est normal ils
sont pas professionnels donc c'est pas
un reproche hein genre nous on
regarderait comme ça puis on passerait
peut-être 10 minutes sur 7h en fait h on
passerait peut-être oui tro fois 10
minutes en 7h et puis c'est tout on
ferait pas plus longtemps non plus
et puis mon ver il dit que lui aussi
c'est comme ça bah oui très bien oui
c'est comme ça en fait c'est pas fait
pour regarder je dirais en soi je sais
pas trop comment direit oui c'est pas
fait pourer nonstop pendant 7h mais
venir voir ce qui se passe ah tiens
c'est intéressant je reste bon oui bon
ça va pas trop bouger je repars je vaens
dans une demi-heure ouais ça se regarde
comme ça en fait mais c'est pour ça
qu'on se limite en terme de partie
d'ailleurs parce que comme on sait que
ça se regarde comme ça ben on dit si on
regarde 10 parties en fait la personne
elle vient elle va jamais tomber sur la
même partie donc elle a pas de fil là
comme on en suit généralement 4 C
maximum la personne qui vient et qui
repart en fait elle va avoir un fil
conducteur des parties
importantes donc on fait pour la casse
mais complètement mugy mais vraiment un
premier degré en fait sinon
oui bah oui ah oui sinon vous garderez
pas quoi
enfin mais pas comme ça mais pas comme
ça
ouais et ouais comme dit WNI lui il
attend plutôt le le contrerendu le soir
ouais c'est plus cool par ça tues 15 20
minutes tuas les tu as la partie entière
à expliquer ouais et à contrario quand
c'est du rapide enin moi je me suis
surpris parfois je me suis pas surpris
une fois un match que je commentais pas
de speedess Ding Naka qui était hyper
serré et tu as regardé pr à le regarder
en j'ai regardé pendant une demi-heure
nonstop alors que normalement les échecs
je regarde vraiment pas quoi enfin c'est
le dernier truc que j'ai envie de
regarder j'en fais tellement mais là le
match é intéressant et j'ai regardé
pendant 30 minutes quoi
tu voulais savoir et çaou bien il a des
jolis coups et ouais sair et même
globalement quand je commande des matchs
comme mvl Carlsen ou quoi globalement si
je les commentais pas je les regarderais
mais les matchs de longue enfin même un
match championnat du monde je pense que
je regarderais pas en direct je
regarderais juste la partie et tu reges
peêtre la dernière ronde J pour quelque
chose al moi je me souviens j'ais
regardé la dernière Crem
niikleco bah oui mais c'est intéressant
parce que parce que c'était la dernière
et crraamnick devait absolument gagner
et Machin et bon et qu'il a joué la
carocan
mais mais oui non globalement en fait
moi dans les tournois que je commmente
globalement ce que je regarderai c'est
les matchs de mvl en en blitz ou quoi
parce que c'est cool euh les les gros
matchs en rapide je regarderai aussi
alors peut-être pas les champions ch
tour parce que bon sur Internet moi j'ai
quand même toujours un peu de mal sauf
si c'est mvl
euh mais genre championnat du monde de
rapide surtout si c'est chaud et tout
Blitz je pe je peux regarder mais mais
même les candidats en fait je
regarderaiis pas enin en direct
attention quand quand quand je parle là
je parle typiquement en direct après
passer les parties en avance rapide je
peux le faire regarder les résultats non
mais regarder les parties regard les
ouvertures qui s'est joué machin siil ve
un truc intéressant euh c'est cool
mais mais du coup oui là c'est pas
spectaculaire quoi on est
d'accord peut-être certains d'endre vont
trouvver spectaculaire mais j'imagine si
mais même la Coupe du monde hein c'était
pasage mais la Coupe du Monde c'est pas
trop long par partie c'est trop long sur
le temps c'est ça du un mois dur un mois
ouais eu ça pourrait si c'était un peu
plus c'est cool mais faudrait que ce
soit plus plus
compact
mais oui Carlsen nepo celle qui a duré
8h ouais moi j'étais content de la
regarder quand même même si c'était long
j'étais content c'était une belle game
Carlsen nepo mais bon c'est un match
championnat du monde il y avait vraiment
de l'enjeu et
puis salut coco puis tu sentais que
c'était une partie importante pour
l'histoire des échecs donc c'est un peu
un peu
différent non mais c'est comme on vous
parlait de Manu Sner ou quoi s en a une
comme ça qu'on retient et et qu'on en
parle encore pendant des années il y a
pas de souci faut pas que tout dure 5
minutes mais non non il y a des choses
qui peuvent durer plus longtemps parfois
maisp céit du gros
kiff le match en soit pas vraiment non
plusf non mais la partie là ouais cé
était bien ça terminé le matchéta
ou c'est bon pour le H exactement
MLS
exactement
ouais c'est un peu c'est un peu comme ça
ça ça ça gagnerait être plus plus
court après surtout moi ce que j'ai
encore du mal à comprendre c'est
pourquoi il y a autant de cadences
différentes dans le cycle du championnat
du monde ça ça me dépasse un peu
j'arrive pas trop à
comprendre qu'en fait il y a vraiment
énormément de cadence V que ào il y a
beaucoup de cadences qui compte c'estd
que toutes ces cadences là font partie
du cycle et je trouve ça assez assez
bizarrece qu'il y a un truc sur les je
sais pas je l'ai pas en tête mais à mon
avis il aura rien contre le fait de soit
plus court mais j'ai pas eu d'interview
en ce
sens après je qu'il aime bien les
longues aussi mais peut-être pas les
très très longues comme ça par qu' a
longue et longue en fait il y a 1h30
plus 30 secondes et 30 minutes donc
c'est plutôt les longues que nous on
aime bien enfin moi pour avoir vu ça ça
va quand même et il y a les très très
longues comme là où là je trouve que
c'est quand même un poil trop
enfin déjà l'autre je trouve que c'est
trop long mais quand
même c'est V qu' a une bonne question
aussi he c'est pourquoi c'est pas la
même cadence homme femme mais je sais
pas ça aussi c'est bizarre ouais enin
homme mixte femme oui mais la question
c'était comme ça j'ai lu la question non
mais mais bon concrètement c'est
vraiment homme là en fait on peut Mme
pas dire ça enfin ça s'appelle mixte
mais non c'est pas la même cadence le
mixte et le femme ce qui est un peu étr
il y a pas mal de trucs en fait bizarres
qui sont pas cohérents tu arrives pas
trop à comprendre mais d'ailleurs je
préfère la cadence du coup du Tour à
femme tour à femme et ouais meilleure
cadence ouais sans aucun
doute c'est cosmiquement incohérent de A
à Z ouais il y a pas trop de de
cohérence
mais à chaque fois ça doit s'expliquer
pour avoir l'habitude de ces trucs là en
fait tout est incohérent mais il y a
toujours une
explication pas forcément intelligente
mais il y en a forcément une ça peut
être comme un truc débile comme les
candidats de femmes ont une autre
cadence que les candidats mixtes
oui mais pourquoi aussi enfin oui mais
tu sais pas peut-être qu'à un moment
donné il y a quelqu'un qui a décidé que
c'était ou queil y a une sission
qu'avant tout MC la même cadence que
quelqu'un a changé un cadence d'un des
deux tournois pour une raison X ou Y que
après c'est resté comme ça parce que tu
sais que quand quelque chose est ben
faut surtout plus changer après
attention c'est très grave de faire du
changement et donc ça reste comme ça et
ça peut être quelque chose de très
débile mais il y a forcément une
explication est-ce que le blit rapide
remplacer le long ben je pense pas enfin
c'est même pas souhaitable en fait les
deux peuvent queexister les trois
d'ailleurs euh après on peut on peut un
peu un peu modifier le LAN que soit un
peu moins lent et c'est tout quoi mais
euh mais chaque cadence a sa raison
d'être ou quoi et puis même le Rapid
Blitz on pourrait lui lu laisser plus de
l're de noblesse parce que souvent c'est
Al il a joué à 5 ici peno B ça va un peu
de mal Enis son truc parce que si les
blancs réussissent à conserver le P F4
au bout d'un moment ça fera vraiment
trop mais peut-être qu'il se dit que il
est plus ou moins dans la poche je sais
pas mais bon pe spinko qui sent la
pression lui aussi hein c'est c'est une
partie à grand jeu pour lui hein donc
autant ça avait l'air
d'être bqué par l'ordi hein ce qu' jou
au début et il aimait bien là l'ordi
aime plus trop al c'est le petit ordi
mais même
visuellement j'aimais mieux les
convensations quand on vit les tours
rentrer le fou le machin la petite
levente qu'on avait regardé que ce que
je vois là
quoi
on verra plus tard c'est pas très
important pour le
moment
ikarou qui ça réfléchit ça fond de cours
après je sais pas combien de temps ça
dur en fa
si peutut-être la jouer très très
longtemps en bougeant pas espérant un
tilt un truc dur à
dire parce que je vois pas vraiment de
plan constructif pour les blancs en fait
je veux
dire un truc qui pourrait nous embêter
ou
mais je vois pas de nul en force direct
non plus quoi c'est juste bon
ben faut jouer des coups quoi
ok C5 ok on pense à F C8 nous
ouais enfin pas que hein mais mais ça me
semblait personnellement le coup logique
et viit il trouve les coup mais tu sais
que c'est peut-être c'est peut-être
Penko qui va être le dindon de la
farce mnerait pas qu'il le soit disons
il a pas un appareillement facile hein
lesir contre guéri c'est c'est jamais
simple c'est pour ça pourrait être le
dindon de la farce et avec voilà partir
en jeu grosse
pression pas
facile il aurait le se bah il a ouais
ouais parce qu'il a vraiment fait un
beau tournoi mais après sur la saison
pour moi vidite mite plus oui parce que
belle Coupe du Monde ouais parce qu'il y
a belle coupe du monde et globalement il
si viennent quoi en fait il enin
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait dernièrement
enfin je vais aller regarder ça fait
longtemps je l'ai pas vu jouer hein non
mais il a joué mais juste il a mal
joué je vais regarder un peu les touris
qu'il a fait cette année mais je crois
qu'il a pas été transcendant alors que
vidit bah il avait baissé wo déjà il est
plus que 26 77 alors il il remonte bien
dans ce tournoi mais alors il a fait
quoi il a joué en
janvier il a joué si Jess cjess il a
rien fait de mais bon il a joué plus ou
moins à son niveau
ok en mars il a gagné quelques points h
il a jou en bundesiga et le WRR Master
et WRR master il a bah il a rien fait en
fait il a fait 4/ 9 non mais c'est
normal enfin quand tu le plateau c'est
ça va oui mais genre tu menaces rien non
euh en juin non en avril pardon il a
joué il a joué le championneur
individuel il a joué à son niveau plus
trois points l' sur le tournoi donc rien
de spécial il a joué en Bundesliga rien
spécial
j
eten il a perdu un petit peu des ouis il
a rien
fait en fait de toute façon on voit bien
ses évolutions de on regarde quand même
il fait rien de spécial il a joué charia
il fait 5 etemi sur ne9 mais
bon il a battu personne
quoi non il battu thodorou après il a
fait compte des 26 mais ouais ok donc il
a rien fait en juillet il a joué il a
beaucoup joué il a joué le mémorial à
vagan pas très bien 4 et demi sur 9
ouais il a jou le Top 16
et bon il a pas trop mal joué au Top 16
mais mais cétait pas une
opposition 6 et dem sur 9 il gagne un
peu des points mais il a rien fait ENF
pour moment il a rien fait de son année
en septembre c'est a priori rien il a
joué la Coupe du Monde il a éliminé
safari éliminé Valero mais en faisant
que des nuls g les départages ouais il a
fait de nul contre g et il a perdu les
départages il a rien fait et et là il a
perdu 5 point dernier tournoi qu'il a
joué super finale de je sais pas quoi
championnat de
Russie il a rien
fait donc oui 6 au championnat de Russie
championnat de Russie tu as Ivan Rosam
je sais pas qui c'est tu avais Katia qui
jouait tu as mourzine tu as Timo feev tu
as matlakov tu as ponratov tuas naer
gariakinarf thomasevsk chef je ok c'est
les mecs à jouer à l'OM bon il vient là
un peu en fin de carrière jouer le non
tu vois c'est pas le championnat de
Russie où tu avais viidler kramnick et
tout le monde et tout le monde là c'est
un championnat de Russie e
plus il y a pas gritchou y a pas kakin
il y a pas kramni pas NPO il y a pas NPO
et tu fais 6 sur tu as rien fait quoi
non non oui il a pas
fait qu'avant le tournoi tu penses pas
qu'il vait se qualifier à gagner le
tournoi d'ici mais bon après il joue
bien ici joue bien ici
quoi c'est vidit c'est peut-être plus
méritant avec son son parcours à la
Coupe du
monde mais bon pr devent quoi écoute il
est là il joue le tournoi d' on l'a pas
vu mais je crois qu'il fait beaucoup de
nul il a d gag de
donc il su son petit bonhomme de chemin
quoi
qui perd ses Games
terrible c'est quoi limitation pour les
joueurs étrangers non non tu peux en
faire jouer que
trois sur
G abasov un peu cata rapport entre Gouch
et ah sur le tournoi peut-être et abasov
ah
ou fait défoncer
j'imagine après
ouaisin pas
il joue c bien ouaisf ça joue ouais dur
à dire il sue quoi mais après pas un
grand blitzer hein donc généralement ça
veut dire Blitz quand même c'est le
talent pur hein h quand tu es pas trop
bon au Blitz
généralement et fait voir s'il y a
d'autres parties qui jouent c'est même
pas pour regarder vra c'est juste pour
cliquer praganonda ben il est là il
finit t la table 6 donc il a pas été
ridicule enfin on l'a juste pas vu table
1 2 enfin il jouait pas la qualif Dee
façon il était déjà qualifié mais il a
fait quoi ben il fait plein il fait nul
nul nul nul nul puis il a battu Gupta et
joue tel que joue ma bayef non mais il a
rien fait de spécial mais pour te dire
ça va quoi c'est pour te dire Fab
okob
Douda
s'envoit d'ailleurs est-ce qu' enfin
finalement il fait quoi il basse sarion
nul nul n nul bag dura nul il fait pas
un grand tournoi mais il va peut-être
gagner encore
qu mais il a jamais été en
course alors que lui on aurait pu croire
que enfin avant le tournoi que peut-être
ok après là c'est vraiment les les
joueurs
battus mais il ont vraiment pas pesé sur
le tournoi là et marquan n'a pas du tout
regardé les dernières tables c'est
presque ouais michra qui a pas mal jouer
le tournoi quand même au final ouais
ouais ouais michra pas mal il faire nul
aujourd'hui contreeno bonjour d'ailleurs
qui est un peu passé à côté mais ouais
je crois que c'est avant dernière table
pour ouais pour Mar tout tout en bas en
bas en bas en bas en bas la zavic tu
vois vu ses résultats sur Internet on
pensait qu'il allait peser sur le
tournoi est top 10 mondial he sur
Internet pas pareil hein il fait très
très mal les champion chest il y a le
plus d'argent est vraiment très très
fort s'attendait à moi je m'attendais à
ce qu'il pèse sur la qualification pour
les candidats la zavic ouais mais là
qu'il fasse parti on va voir un peu ses
résultats on a pas trop vibré avec lui
là moi je pensais qu'il se met à la à la
qualification et finalement il fait quoi
nul corobof nul blterche défaite lent
nul nul latacha nul Pya défaite sadani
nul nul nul nul ouais c'est étonnant je
m'attendais à le voir un feu d'artifice
un feu d'artifice être un peu la
surprise du tournoi et marquant qui va
peut-être terminer par une nul a priori
Bion de MO reposé ça l'air assez solide
mais j égyptien faut oui Fay bof aussi
on pouvait s'attendre à ce qu'il pèse he
quand même sur le tournoi après sa
victoire en Coupe du monde on est étonné
Fab canadien là qui est pas très
bien on dit la derrière table le Blitz
c'est le talent pur alors oui mais très
bon blitzer sur Internet après il y a
aussi les spécialistes et du coup qui
peut avoir du mal à passer de la 2D à la
3D transition pasentr c'est encore un
autre problème donc il pèse pas en 3D
plus fort en
2D une W car candidat pour été l'homme
qui a terrassé Magnus alors en classique
sur de matchs alors il a pas joué en
classique en plus c sur internet en plus
il y a pas de card donc c'est il y a pas
mal de problèmes
il y a pas de car cette année ce qui est
pas bête mais
bon
ce qui même
bien2 est-ce qu'il veut tour
B4 je peux faire fou
des7 joli à il l' vu he
bien sûr je pense et puis ok on rend un
pion on a tout consolidé la tour vient
en jeu et on a majorité
mais en plus on est mieux en place ouais
et j'ai 4 qui va arriver pe-êre va
arriver changer tu as peut-être le plan
et P B peut être faible oua le Roi peut
me courir en E3 D4 C4 je pensais qu' 5
c'était son idée Tor B4 je crois que
c'était son idée et
ouis si tu fais Tor B5 à 3 c'est assez
joli ce qu 2 à
3 ben écoute ça prend forme pour guérir
et du du coup V tu as pas trop de raison
de
s'exciter quelque part cétait le tournoi
des vieux B vach avec l'ami il a une 10
points ils sont mêlés les premières
tables je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
à ciel bleu en fait pour moi quand même
quand tu regardes un tourno à la fin je
regarde pas les joueurs qui ont gagné
des points l' je regarde ceux qui ont
pesé sur la qualification
systématiquement parce que gagner des
points l' ça veut enfin ça veut dire que
tu fais un bon tournoi relativement à
toi-même mais ça veut pas dire que tu
pèses sur le tournoi et des joueurs
comme Baky vtasek lami alors ils ont pas
été favorisés par ça mais comme c'est
joueurs qui jouent pour faire nul qui
s'en fichent un petit peu euh ils se
sont mis dans la position avec
l'expérience et leur style de jeu ou
quelque part c'était parfait pour eux
parce que les autres voulaient
absolument gagner pour jouer les
premiers plans et ils ont pu en profiter
alors plus ou moins parce que l'ami je
crois qu'il a fait un bon début après il
est retombé ouais il était bien dans
synchrone je pense l'ami dans le
classement je t sais que c'était sur le
T en fait c'est Baky qui a fait le mieux
qui a le plus pesé qui a le plus pesé
euh vtassek en fait il ouais on a jamais
trop pensé qu'il a se qualifieré mais il
est franchement c'est pas un mec facile
à jouer vtassekin il a été autour de
2750 pendant très longtemps et très très
bien préparé était dans l'équipe de
secondant d'Anand quand à une époque et
là tu vois bon mais maintenant il est
moins motivé puis il a un peu vieilli ou
quoi mais ça fait pas plaisir de Jer ce
mec à 2660 quoi enfin tu le bat pas en
le balayant en rvers de la main quoi
c'est donc il fasse le tournoi plus ou
moins je pense qu'il a dû être invaincu
vek voilà il a pas il avait pas une
ambition débordante j'imagine hein
mais c'est juste que de toute façon il
est mal classé et quand il va jouer il
il va plutôt prendre des points je pense
hein
mais j'aion que ce truc de toute façon
dans ce tournoi là quand tu es solide
sur les appuis que tu es tu es bien pour
faire des nuls je pense que ce type de
tournoi là c'est vraiment ce qui te
convient le mieux h parce que les autres
ils ont envie de gagner et de force un
peu la porte et bah après faut bien que
ça commence genre B qui sa victoire
contre darda au noir elle est hyper
importante à la première ronde ah bah
oui il faut aller la chercher oua faut
aller la chercher sinon après après tu
dois résister quand tuas contre Guiry
tuas beau vouloir faire nul faut faut
encore non c'est sûr mais gen je trouve
que ça convient bien pour le style après
il faut le faire évidemment he et donc
ouais et donc ouais vet je pense qu'il
est mieux pour gagner des points dans un
tournoi comme ça que si tu l'envoies à
6js ou je sais pas où où il va être
lui-même favori à devoir battre des des
2450 motifés 25 et reste de faire aussi
quand même pas mal de
nul et donc donc voilà c'est juste aussi
que bah ouais c'est un format qui qui va
pas mal quoi après tu as cité quelques
noms de gens qui pèsent avec des petits
h mais tu as pas cité celui qui pèse le
plus sur le tournoi dans les petits ho
enfin supposé petit c'est prê que il est
que 26 60 et il joue la Calif à la
dernière ronde
ouais ouais ououais il fait vraiment un
beau tournoi pr ça devrait pas suffire
mais écoute qui ça tu il a il a quand
même tu as dit bon battu Douda annul
cpenko on voit qu' est pas n'importe
quoi puisque c'est lui qui a mené la
danse erigizi keer chankland Nakamura B
ch il a joué du
lourd mais ouais il
pèse il y a le kazak à 24 40 aussi qui a
pesé il fait quoi aujourd'hui il est un
peu sombré vers la fin mais écoute lui
peut cont son
touroncer il a très bien commencé il a
un peu moins bien fini mais bonement je
pense fatigué quoi tout le monde te joue
à fond et c'est dur chaque
jour est-ce que je reviendrai à SAÉ don
un stage d'échec j'ai jamais donné de
stage peut-être je fa des aprè des trucs
comme ça mais
mon rater la
pause avant le les amis on sera très
vite de retour à à
[Musique]
toute
he he
[Musique]
he he he
he
al mesdames et messieurs il y a eu une
petite avancée alors c'est ce à quoi on
s'attendait ikarou est venu échanger les
dames donc comme on le disait il vient
faire ça
nul on sait pas trop si là c'est le 30e
coup s ils vont peut-être faire nul ou
si ikarou va un peu jouer le gar le truc
c'est il peut vraiment pas essayer il va
rien jouer ikarou mais ikarou va rien
jouer non plus surtout que ça se passe
bien à
côté vidit il a trouvé le cavalier prend
à 6 donc ça commence à chauffer pour la
Calif d'ikarou mais nos espoirs en
réalité reposent plutôt sur sur Guiri
qui après tout reprend des 4 semble
simplement gagnant donc ça va en fait et
donc gu C exactement ligne qu'on avait
dit avec le T B4 et tout ça qui était
pas facile mais bravo à guéri d'avir
trouvé en fait ouais
ouais A3 là c'est le C intermédiaire qui
fait mal au qui fait mal au noir quoi et
du coup il arrive à avoir cette finale
alors tour prend B4 il va tenter CAH D5
tour B8 3 H7 et là peut-être G3 faudra
réussir à se dépatouiller sûrement par
roi1 roi D1 et après envoyer P euh
ouais et qui D5 tu peux aussi faire tour
D4
ouais peut-être d'ailleurs moi j'ai mis
la tour en B8 pour faire un échec mais
oui cavaler7 peut-être
ouais mais en fait c'est bien là le plan
de ouais ouais ouais ben peut-être t
maintenant mais oui je comprends c'est
ouais ça va être juste pour des gens
tiens si on fait B4 qui enfin avec avec
mon truc ouais ou là ouais ça d'ord ça
va ça va laisser la case B2 à la Tour
Noire qui va venir se mettre derrière et
qui va nous embêter h plus dur d'avancer
et du coup en faisant l'autre plan avec
ro ro D1 ça extipe cette tour d'ici et
après on peut pousser B mieux
quoi bah du coup gu qui va peut-être
rendre un fier
service à la fois viite et à la fois
quoi
tu peux faire tour B8 ro H7 G3 protège
son pion ils ont H4 et tour B5
maintenant
b35ou toutes
lesas tout dégagé et
aprèsance
B
je pense que même sans le pion de plus
de l'autre côté tu très bien mais avec
le pion de
plus mais oui qui peut vraiment nous
rendre une très très fière chandprs
attention reg des
point àir mais bon on peut pas tout
demander pe pas tout lui demander pe pas
être au four et au moulin le beur et
l'argent du
beur6
j CIS que c'est
dur ser à rien mais dans le mouvement
c'est complèement nul ok faire nul don
clairement il pourra pas se qualifier
fallait qu'il gagne et que les qure
figures soi favorable mais ça c'est mort
laavic Batt Mar pour finir on verra pas
sûr alors ils ont pas signé nul encore
mais
[Musique]
voilà prê que c'est une partie qui aura
son importance pour la Calif cas de
victoire de Guiry mais nous en soit ça
changera plus rien mais ça semble mal se
diriger pour près de que en fait j'aais
pas à cause de6 et je sais pas enfin je
mets pas visuellement je sais pas ce qu'
l'a pas vu par en fait il l' il l'USS
pens qu'il a tour à 8 et mais si je fais
allez
A3 pere qu'il a un truc comme ça ok il
ve en faire une cavalier fait j'ai vu le
coup de l'ordi sur tour à8 c'était de
faire fous C3 en disant je t'attaque ton
cavalier je me suis libéré la classe B4
aussi pour le mien et je vais revenir
sur mes pas et défendre à deux mais F C3
c'est pas un coup enfin expliquer comme
ça il est très logique mais c'est pas si
simple très dur ouais c'est pour ça que
je parlais moi d'un coup comme un autre
quoi à 3 ou quoi mais mais donc il a dû
le trouver tous nos espoirs
retour reposent sur anich gué gu Maxime
nous dit qu'il se qualifierait
probablement au circuit s'il gagnait
cette partie en fait
ouais mais du coup il y aurait saut
ouais mais là bon sa on peut
pas nous on veut vraiment qu'il a plus
personne quoi qui puisse s'approcher
d'Alia mais oui on y avait pensé hier
des au circuit cétait pour ça qu'il
était si motivé on pensait en fait ouais
du coup si so gagne laraent beaucoup de
points peut-être qu' circuit mais faut
pas que gu gagne trop de points ça
recommence les mêmes
conneries non il va pas être top 2 gu
top rien du tout enfin il va finir 5e ou
un joli truc hein mais pas il va pas se
qualifier ici non mais ça va vraiment
jouer sur gu parce que près de que je
crois vraiment que ça va perdre mais
comment te dire
euh il y a donc plusieurs canaux pour te
qualifier donc il y avait la Coupe du
Monde il y a trois joueurs par la Coupe
du Monde tu en as deux ici donc c'est
pas Guiri tout ça tu as une place au hlo
à priori c'est pas Guiri mais tu as une
place au circuit feed al circuit feed
c'est quoi c'est des tournois homologués
par la f o tu marques des points un peu
comme les Grand Prix de Formule 1 tu
peux en jouer que 5 que qui comp Mme
joue 10 on prend meilleurs
résultat é en course mais àheure
actuelle le leader c'était carwana déjà
qualifiéenlève et G qui
tenait Calif sauf que bon ici joue pas
bien donc il marqua pas de point et gu
en un très bon tournoi ici en finissant
dans dans les premières places ça va lu
améliorer son score et du coup il
pourrait enfin il doublera Gouch et donc
ça serait lui qui aurait cette place
pour l'instant donc après ça peut
dépendre de ce que ferait s'il unefi ou
je ne sais quoi mais gu ça le met plutôt
en bonne posture donc voilà gu c'est pas
une partie anecdotique pour lui il joue
vraiment pour quelque chose et et donc
il est motivé pour essayer de de
l'emporter pas juste pour faire plaisir
à vidite quoi 7950 sa 7884 et guér 75 15
87 mais là s'il gagne aujourd'hui il va
marquer des gros punos alors après je
sais pas comment on calcule he pour le
coup mais mais donc bah faudrait qu'il
améliore son son moins bon score de
genre 5 points et il passe devant al
peut-être que notre ami Rigi est en
train de s'envoyer en l'air en fait 3 D7
B5 AB AB cavalier à 5 enfin peut-être
qu'il est en train juste de perdre tout
seul ok mais bon s'il veut se qualifier
en même temps non mais il a raison mais
je dire a priori tu vas pas mettre trop
en danger nakaka en faisant ça en tu as
juste en pourri la position mais euh
écoute je il a la bonne attitude non
mais j'uris fait pareil donc
mais après bon peut-être qu'il va
s'arrêter avec le pion B4 juste bouger
la tour faire C3 et et pas faire pire
quoi
ouais il y aura des points à singfield
pour le turirc ouais mais gcash ne le
joue pas donc déjà ouais en plus il a
déjà des bons scores donc est-ce qu'il
aurait réussirait vraiment à m'améliorer
quoi que ce soit surtout vu sa forme il
est complètement NZ en ce moment je
disais c'est plus goûche c'est
prune est quand même content c'est la
saison des kaki là qui arrive qui qui
bat son
plein mais fait quoi aujourd'hui gche on
Ava regardé on sait pas trop
contbi ça
joue il faire un système de long non vu
la tronche de la position mais une
qualité de plus regarder
jusqu-ce qu'il a joué une idée
intéressante même
pas truc un peu modern qui Fa un
peu il a de dans la théorie mais je veux
dire H6 joli coup
non prise alors là c'est pas
deexclamation ouais bon
aprè
ah oui mais bon oui non mais
d'accord il l' défoncé quoi ouais mais
tu qu' su quoiob c'est pas non plus ah
non mais oui fa que suer en fait double
blanc en plusimpression que il un peu
les planètes qui s'alignent de partout
il se fait quand même défoncer
quoi il a quand même fait des nul contre
2650 4 fois il perd de fois 2650 une
fois 258 il bat 25 60 nul 26 19 défaite
2784 la nul contre le représentant du
seum et là bon il joue contre un vieux
enfin enin combien il a qu' à 60 ans
quoif fou peut-être pas tout à fait mais
oui il est plus de première ou mais bon
enfin mieux c'est plus 0,58 va se
prendre dam 6 il peut-être tué non je
veux dire que même 25 4 an il a pas du
tout peur de lui en fait il le prend
pour
un pour un abrutax
quoi serait beau qu' Cobian il le batte
quoi ça ferait encore combien quand Mo
moins 7 points et demi un truc comme ça
ce serait beau quoi ilit complètement
écraser tu es pas dou en
blit là il est combien actuellement il a
27 17 ah il retombera à 2710
quoi derrière un tel que
douof non mais ça enin ça ferait plaisir
on s'en fiche complètement aussi mais on
est heureux enfin on est heureux de tout
he nous avec Fab toujours
hein CELI qui me fait peur c'est [__]
pas beaucoup d'avance sur saut et gu qui
revient aussi
je pense que la SF ça être la SF de
toutes les peurs quoi
tu pe avec une certaine avance mais
faudra pas faire n'importe
quoi mais bon à un moment comme je te
dis hein faut un petit peu mériter quand
même une calife quoi
mais ça être marrant à suivre oui Mo
quelque chose mais c'est déjà beau
d'avoir de l'avance en fait
ouais ça représente pas ce qui se passe
depuis 2 ans dans le CC des échecs on
dire en tout cas pas du tout mais après
REM jouer
faire j'espère pour lui que ça le
motiver mais j'en sais
rien
[Musique]
à cause il ve
clairement846
trouvable
[Musique]
trouvable trouvable parce que forc après
faut mais trouvable parce que forc mais
tu peux pas le faire encore plus
facile pas facile en
fait exercice tuas photographierend
photo
trouvable mais pas facile oua mais
trouvable déjà de savoir qu'il y a un
truc ça t'aide ah mais trouve pas mais
tu vois c'est pas facilean oui mais
bon oui oui oui non mais bien sûr je
dois quand même trouver un truc un jour
tu peuxettre la position avant par du
coup j'ai pris la photo le déjà en G2
quoi non mais c'était dur mais oui non
mais bien sûr c'était dur mais bon un
moment donné tu aller au
candidat coup quoi mais ouais c'était
pas ouis on pe remontrer si vas cétait
joli alors B cétait k F7 donc bon l'idée
cl c'est de te clouer et puis tu te fais
bouffer le cavalier je dis ah merde en
fait donc bon tu bouges il prend ton
cavalier sin tu t'en vas et là le coup
hyper dur c'est E6 tu donnes il est
obligé de prendre parce qu'il a forch TR
tours tu Fautre chose voilà tu prends le
pion to reprends C6 du coup échec tac
tac tu bouges ton ro on bouffe ton
cavalier et tu as une finale avec un
plus même là fallait avoir ça en plus
mais si tu te fais bouffer ta tour tu
bouffes l'utre et sil s'en va bah tu vas
prendre à 6 tu vas faire tour G6 ou je
sais pas quoi et et
voilà et ouais bah il a raté non mais
comment dit c'était peut-être trouv
enfin c'était trouvable mais fallait
être affuté et pas facile en tout
caser je pense qu'on peut la virer ouais
la zavi on sait pas pourquoi on suit non
bon ça ça ça position est sympa j'en l'a
laissé C C qui tente le dame à
6 pour aller peut-être rentrer vers A2
et cetera
il a tous les coups Guiry joue bien là
je tour B3 ouais tour3 ça l'air vraiment
fort mais a tour B7 aussi qui peut être
sympa mais c'est bien quand même si on a
Guiri au candidat ah ouais gu c'est
mérité et puis il peut enfin j'y crois
pas mais en fait tu peux pas le rayer de
la carte d'avance non non non tu peux
pas dire Guiri gagnera pas le tournoir
il a quand même gagné
VI non mais son me c'est qu'il VI pas
ass en général mais il peut y arriver en
fait c'est ouais il pas favori pour mais
il peut basof mais même pragananda ça me
saoule en
fait bon pire ça fait un jeune ça va
abasof bon abasof oui ça ça fait plaisir
à personne mais bah ça lui fait
peut-être plaisir à lui oui
oui est loin de Ali quand même ben moi
je trouve plus fort enfin je vois pas
pourquoi il serait moins je pense qu'il
parle au ho mais
mais c'est pas histoire de ho là Guiry
c'est par le circuit Fed c'est ce qu'on
disait mais
ouais mais puis après je sais pas si par
Mirac Carlsen finalement décide de jouer
les candidats et là tuas une belle
lineup car tu aurais quoi si Carlsen
finalement jouis jou tu aurais Carlsen
carwana
ikarou NPO
Sirou voilà les deux K et Pr ok bon bon
pourquoi pas ENF je dire il a le droit
d'être là et c'est tout je c'est beau
quoi mais ça change complètement la
c'est vent parce que ça te change tout
mais parce que ça te met le meilleur du
monde versus un plot
absoluas après si ça joue sur C TER
abasof il a montré qu'il était très fort
mais ça joue pas sur C mais si ça joue
en Azerbaidjan je pense ça aurait pu
être un sacré client ouis mais bon ça
joue au Canada ça joue à Toronto et
c'est pas facile de se
déplacer
mais oui le problème de Carls c'est que
il joue ça le fait chier de se qualifier
quoi ça faitier de
jouer ça serait beau de jouer juste pour
pour empêcher ikarou quoi
s gagne aujourd'hui les pu ouais mais en
fait le truc
va se qualifier en fait il sera déjà
qualifié donc le son h on s'en fout il
pourrait même dépasser fierou et que en
fait ça changerait pas le fond du truc
ça ch en fait non mais les règles sont
bizarres enfin c'est vrai que bon les
règles sont bizarres et que et que c'est
pas évident de de capter tous les trucs
hein aprs il était sû pas là ouioui
c'est ça oui c'est vra qu'on 10 secondes
mais oui comme des gens viennent partent
et cetera vous êtes pas là toute la
journée à écouter évidemment des fois
oui c'est juste ça nous fait rire parce
qu'on a dit littéralement 30 secondes
avant quoi en plus pas une fois mais
deux et si abasof et Magnus se pointent
pas alors ce sera l'élo du coup après la
place et c'est bien
aussi
euh alors c'est on regarde quoi là
regarde on
regarde après je crois que Naka joue le
truc pour faire le plus nul parce qu'il
doit voir que l'autre elle est gagnante
et donc il a foutu sa tour en C8 non
mais il a raison enfin oui oui mais je
pense
que
mais après candidf sur la saison serait
plus logique d'avoir
candidat il joue nettement mieux c année
il
mais est deè 3è
actuellement
truc sa bonne forme du dernier cycle
quand il était monté à 2008o depuis ça
fond mais ça fond doucement parce qu'il
joue peu et du coup qu' bénf son hlo et
que là il a fait le minimum en jouant le
moins possible que ça passe encore
craque quoi mais faudra pas compter
là-dessus pour un prochain cycle
quoi si car change d'avis il prend la
place à la Coupe du
[Musique]
monde
et je sais pas par contre quand tu sa
deadline pour dire officiellement je
joue je ne joue
pas un jour avant le début du tournoi vu
les
règles non mais là encore il rate des
gains à 26 40 un moment
donnéou non mais je te dis pas qu'il
joue bien
all
en tout cas la S fiel Cup va être
finalement le tournoant en long le plus
intéressant de l'année que il va y avoir
une place au candidat et que ça va
vraiment être la guerre et que on va
pouvoir bien bon celuilà l'était mais
bon maintenant il est fini
donc non mais là il y a une guerre enfin
en fait dans le contenu c'est
intéressant comme on vous dit ce qu'on
reproche c'est la durée des parties on
peut être d'accord pas d'accord et
cetera
mais mais voilà et du coup c'est field
bah ça va être
important en gros faut pas que marque un
point de plus c plus ou moins quoi ouais
c'est vite
arriv c'est fin c'est fin éal VO
donc donc ou ça pe peut se passer des
choses
quoi je crois que ouais que gu
gé très facilement cette partie alors ça
partait pas trop pour il était
grandement retard à la pendule il Savit
bien ce qu'il jouit puis un moment il a
juste plus trouvé les
coups ouais ouais il y aura il y aura gu
aussi
d'ailleurs ça commence dans 2 semaines
en plus nous dit l ouais en plus ala il
va enchaîner ça il va enchaîner le
rapide de la
sofil et la SF Cup je suis pas sûr que
soit une super idée pour lu jouer le
rapide avant mais après il a de la caass
non oui non mais oui mais c'est vrai tu
joues que pour la caass j'ai oublié mais
en plus c'est vra bah quand
même c'est quand même
terrible la
caillass a été TR dans le féminin mais
seul la chaîne anglophone en parler bah
elle est pas qualifiée he enfin je
c'est c'est terrible on suit championnat
mix mais les gens te critiquent parce
que tu suis championnat mix c'est
terrible c'est déjà pas facile de tout
suivre là il s'est passé tellement de
choses tour B6 sûrement
je me demandais juste à titre c'est pas
que j'is
mais4end H2
et G reprends 5 je pensais que ça gagna
mais ok
H3 H3 fait
mal la la la petite n machin
il va jouer à
[Musique]
fond son espoir c'estar de faire C4 B5
ou ais4 je sais pas quoi mais bon enfin
bon il a raison d'essayer je peux pas
trop critiquer c'est c'est chiant pour
nous que ce soit pas signé mais mais a
raison donc enfin moi si j'étais son son
agent ah oui oui ça ferait nul tout de
suite ça traînerait
pas c'est vraiment facile pr non non
c'est pas facile casse pas on a dit que
c'était pas facile mais
c'est bon pour un tel joueur tu peux
trouver nous tu nous en exercice on
trouve après en partie on peut tous
passer à côté facilement parce que bah
tu sais pas que tu as un truc à trouver
c'est la différence entre un exercice
non mais en partie nous on l'aurait
probablement raté mais mais tu peux
aussi le trouver parce que c'est une
suite forcée en fait et tu calcules tu
avances les coups et mais il faut juste
du coup euh songer à pousser la variante
regardez qu' pr ah merde il y a tour la
f c'est fini
quand mêmea c'est un jouur qui est en
course pour se qualifier autour à des
candidats donc à un moment donné il va
quand même falloir trouver un truc enfin
trouver un coup trouver un coup ouais
par qu'il a raté contreevin d'une
position relativement facile après pour
leur niveau là il rate ça enfin il rate
beaucoup quand même même mi peut-être
c'était possible de faire mieux contre
Bartel je sais pas enfin autant bon il a
fait qu' des C qui étaaiit pas bon mais
je la finale Bartel a trouvé à qu mais
peut-être qu'avant tu peux faire
différemment je sais pas puis il a quand
même fait le Pr le 4 il a raté une
tactique enfin il rate quand même
énormément de choses un moment donné et
ça ça peut être juste aussi le manque de
pratique et manque d'énergie manque de
tout quoi mais rate des truc qui qui
ratit beaucoup moins avant ou qui ratait
pas du tout d'ailleurs avant
ouais peut-être qu'il travaille moins
bah je pense je pense que oui
franceide oui mais oui on a réussi à
pourir à non mais parce que quand il a
fait son 8 sur 9 là coupe d'OPE
championnat d'Europe il it pas tout ça
quoi c'est quoi ouais bien joué
nordybeck qui euh qui échange son pion
qui reprend un peu d'espace qui souffle
et ça devrait faire nul une belle
spfiron en calcule bah enfin avant non
mais actuellement peut-être que oui hein
mais il est fort Maxim en calculle mais
c'est peut-être pas le même calcul ENF
je sais pas trop en fait Dison Maxime il
voit très
vite une vision instantanée des des
tactiques quoi et des choses comme ça et
a un très bon sens de
l'initiative mais je dire qu'il y a un
genre de vision hibou
ouais droite de régression et tout quoi
et alors que ouais firou je sais pas
trop comment c'est son calcul ou quoi
mais mais c'était costaud enfin en tout
cas là il fait plus de gaffe quoi plus
de gaffe plus de raté que ce qui nous a
habitué il veut liquideer avec B6 mais
oui son tour C8 c'était quand même pas
pas fou
quoi c'était quand même plus logique de
commencer par roi des7 je sais pas trop
pourquoi il a pas fait il doit y avoir
une raison
hein o tous ressemble et mais c'est
sûrment pas optimal mais ça doit ouais
ça va enfin la perce de F au championnat
de Belet c'est impressionnant quand même
ouais mais ENF c'est quand même ouais
mais le BET c'est pas du calcul c'est du
clic
quoi c'est pas enfin c'est de la vision
on va dire le BET c'est que tu vois les
patterns instant et euh donc c'est une
qualité évidemment mais on peut pas
appeler ça du
calcul il disent F est-ce que ça lui
suffit pas d'être top 10 monde et de
faire de la cayas à son âge ouais mais
bon la ouais peut-être qu'il se rend pas
compte à quel point c'est pas assez en
fait fait non mais c'est sûr que ça doit
lui suffire et qu'il il s'assoit
là-dessus et il se dit ok cool ma vieouû
euh juste en fait à un moment ça veut
pas dire que ta place va être gravée
enfin tu perds des ho regarde lesevon ou
d'autres bon après une fois que tu es
plus là bah tu es plus là et bah les
ordinateurs vont inviter d'autres
joueurs et cetera donc après ben c'est
enfin comme je te dis c'est comme s'il
est heureux comme ça non mais il y a pas
de problème en fait c'est sa vie hein on
n'est pas là pour juger celle des autres
et que lui tout tout lui va très bien
euh pour l'instant en tout cas ça va
hein je pense quand il fait des tournois
il est bien payé il a ses sponsorings il
a ses trucs donc pour l'instant c'est
c'est cool mais c'est pas dit avec la
pente que ça prend en ce moment que ça
dure éternellement je me fais pas de
souc P dans un an ou deux mais tu vois
si c'est comme ça pendant encore un
petit moment dans 5 ans tu le vois plus
dans les gros tournois et les
sponsorings du coup bah ils vont se
tourner vers d'autres et Machin et bon
c'est une autre histoire quoi après bon
si' dapide pas tout qu'il investit
correctement je te dis je fais pas trop
de souci pour lui quoi mais ça dépend de
son train de vide plein de choses ça moi
j'en sais rien en fait
hein mais donc donc voilà pour l'instant
il a juste perdu on va dire son avance
par rapport aux autres joueurs de son
âge donc c'est encore rien de dramatique
si tu remets les bouchées doubles ou
quoi tu peux complètement revenir il a
encore que 20 ans mais après voilà le
temps tourne et et ok si tu travailles
pas tu travailles pas quoi et
normalement tu perds en plus ce goût du
travail donc après c'est d'autant plus
dur de T
remettre tu connais ça Fab
ouais enfin je sais pas enfin oui si
[Musique]
ENF bah moi en fait je travaille
différement en fa je travaille plus du
tout pour moi aux échecs en tant que
joueur mais je fais d'autres trucs à
côté donc je peux pas dire que je
travaille moins qu'avant je travaille
probement plus plus du tout en tant
joueur ok
bravo
qui va peut-être se sécuriser une place
au candidat via
le via le le machin comment s'appelle
déjà la r il dis Naka qualifié ben non
Naka faut pas perdreut pas perdre c'est
pas fait encore paril fait pas une super
parti mais ça va il gère bien pour ne
pas perdre pour l'instant mais attention
ENF on n pas à l'abri d'un d'un miscilic
quoi
et et qu'est-ce que je voulais dire et
gu ouais en fait du coup il peut avoir
peur de sa lui aussi quoi sa peut
griller tout le monde à la race guéri ou
firou au
classement est-ce que je gagne un peu
d'argent les petits non pas mais en fait
là je joue quasi plus
moi c'est pas du tout à pour être une
source de revenir en tout cas nak il a
pas super bien
joué dans Laar il aura aussi le rapide
et le blit ouais mais je pense que so il
ira juste pas en fait rapide et blit il
va jamais
ouais n'intéresse
pas je crois qu'il s'en fout je pense
que jouer les candidats ils s'en fout il
s'en fout de tout mais le truc c'est
quand il joue il joue quoi non mais
quandou il joue mais je pense que les
candidats ça l'intéresse pas plus que ça
non mais rienintéresse faire même gagner
une partie ça l'intéresse pas mais après
sil a sa position que machin bah écoute
non je pense c'est quelqu'un qui aime
pas trop jouer mais qui aime bien gagner
de enfin qui doit c'est son travail en
fait pas mais juste ça fait chier de
jouer aux échecs je pense
bah en interview il a déjà un peu dit
sans dire complètement mais aimait pas
les prépa que machin que cétait trop de
stress que c'était chiant enfin
ou c'est vrai qu' faut quand même bien
acheter les croquettes au chat
quoi c'est mort pour effectivement qui
qui a fait un beau tournoi mais qui a
chuté sur la dernière
marche la marche culot de
courte B qui bah qui a fait
nul comme
Maxime tou beaucoup de gens son des goût
du jeu bah faudra le demander à tous
mais en fait le problème encore une fois
c'est pas le jeu c'est tout ce qui est à
côté maintenant avec les ordis et les
les préparations et tout ce que tu dois
te mettre dans la tête et tout ça et
c'est en ça que moi je vous dis que
j'aime bien le 960 par ça enlèver ce
problème et que toute façon maintenant
c'est comme ça enfin taime t'aime pas de
toute façon si toi tu veux pas utiliser
l'ordi les autes le front et et
donc marquan a fait nul aussi c'est bien
euh donc en fait tu es obligé si tu veux
être compétitif tu as pas le choix et ok
mais tu dois t'en mettre plein à la tête
tu dois regarder l'ordi c'est même plus
donc tellement de la créativité machin
c'est et donc donc
voilà mais c'est je pense ça qui rend un
peu les joueurs moins heureux ah ben ça
rend pas heureux hein c'est c'est vrai
se travail à l'ordi bon mais tu dois fa
enfin oui dès que tu le fais plus ben tu
vas te prendre des mecs qui vont rest 25
coups toi tu tu es là tu joues même plus
contre ton adversaire tu jou contre
stock finish enfin ça peut te coûter
jusqu'à 150 POS lo à mon avis donc euh
euh donc
écoute après je sais pas faudra demander
à sa tu vois je réponds pour lui ce que
je peux répondre mais mais il a déjà dit
he dans les interview je pense machin et
tout ouais
c'est du coup c'est pénible qu'il
prennent des MOC pour la concentration
benah je pense pas des fois il y a des
tests antidopage tu as pas le droit de
faire touer n'importe quoi hein
ro
des il rest quoi comme tournoi ben il va
y avoir la sfield en fait la sfield
voilà pour les caif après tu auras du
monde rapid et Blitz et cetera des
choses comme ça tu as plein de tournois
tu as la coupe de le championnat d'urope
des nations enfin les échecs ça joue
tout le temps de toute façon mais dans
les tournois où ça peut jouer pour les
candidats il y a plus glassing que field
en gros
hein et pour les BTA blocant je sais pas
trop mais euh ouais en fait tu as une
enfin les éche comme c'est considéré
comme un sport tu as tu as une liste de
produits à pas vraiment prendre quoi et
euh d'ailleurs je sais pas sielle est
bien faite la liste genre je veux dire
un truc débile mais prendre de la
créatine je suis pas sûr que ça va trop
améliorer tes performances aux échec et
[Musique]
euh et et ça peut plus utile dans
d'autres sports mais je pense que tu as
pas trop le droit quand même quoi enfin
du coup moi j'ai pas vraent consulté la
liste
mais mais bref ouais tu peux pas tu peux
pas essayer d'améliorer des performances
comme ça
quoi après tout ça ce serait marginal
hein le pire c'est d'augmenter bah en
vibrant avec des plug et compagnie hein
ça c'est c'est le dopage le plus
efficace et celui contre lequel on
aimerait bien arriver à lutter déjà mais
même tout ce qui est
autre prendre des produits ou quoi
normalement pas trop
possible l'ét volcan j'en prends pour
l'hypertension ouis mais après si tu as
une une ordonnance médicale tu as le
droit de prendre des trucs que les
autres ont pas le droit de prendre en
fait je pense la ligne c'est au droit
des tour à 3 à 5 en fait c'est la ligne
de l'ordi je l'ai calculé sans l'ordi en
fait c B4 à T à 5 quand même et il y a
plus rien il y a plus rien allez Koo et
si tu commences par A5 bah du coup il y
a bat on prend k C5 c'est quand même pas
très dur he parce qu' quelqu' qui dur
enfin ro des6 c'est le coup que tu joues
en betette normalement après des fois tu
te fais des nœuds dans la tête mais
là mais du coup ou non si vous AZ une
prescription médicale il y a pas de
c'est pour ça que dans le cyclisme crois
sont tous asmatiqu ouais tout le Ploton
est
asthmatique faire exprès de perdre non
il fera pas exprès de perdre non c'est
pas le genre de quoi
que non mais il va pas faire ça enfin
sinon j pas en fait
enfin c'est
non ce serait
bizarre
et visite juste pour il fait
quoi il visite vidite ouis r
si ok bah il est plutôt mieux
paraît-il bah il va se trouver unamp de
plus non si tu reprends à 5 tu prends un
tu peux pas prendre à de il fou
B5 est-ce que tu proposes nul à sa place
bah pourquoi pas tu t'en fous bah les
candidats c'est c'est plus important de
gagner ce tourno hein mais sur tu peux
pas gagner
que'en fous
oui je n en fait là lui s fait nul c'est
déjà
bon je fer nul maison il do attendre le
30è coup mais moi je
ferai tellement des ordures non mais là
c'est juste que tu joues les
circonstance je suis content qu'il je
trouve que sur la saison il mérite
plus il est plus fort et c'est bien que
ce soit lui qui
aille ser beau qu'il fasse exprès de
perdre le dépasse au ho ah ce serait
mérité si jamais il fait exprès de
perdre mais mais non mais il va pas
faire
ça on ser près de que il ferait
3è bon ok fait un beau
tournoi pe tu faire k C5 pour pas faire
nul direct K5 pensais à
quoi non je vais faire à 5 quand même ça
va pas marcher ouais c'était pour ça qu'
c'est 5 ouais mais euh mais oui donc du
coup c'est des4 j'avais en fait j'avais
aussi je me rappelais plus ce que vu
ouais j'avais vu ça ça ça et ça j'avais
en faitant qu'on parlait j'ai calculé le
truc non faut ramener le j'ai comisé
pour
dire tuux pas t'embêter avec la finale
de Tours
tour
F6 je pense qu'il a tout vu nak oui
oui fait nul gag le
tournoah prier ou deè en tout cas prier
ou deè à
coupû sassure la
Calif
il nous assure une magnifique s fi
Cup de tous les
dangers
exactement on fera les analyses à fond
au moins ouais ouais oua ouais tous les
jours machin plus j'aime bien c'est le
soir signé je crois sur ch ah ouais ben
il y a peut-être déjà les les résultat
on va aller jeter un œil après c'est une
information ludwiig ouais signer Naka
Naka candidat mesdames et messieurs
c'est l'information Ikaru Nakamura
qualifié pour les candidats c'est
l'information c'est l'information
information de
large donc
ouais la photo des cpenco elle est
terrible ouais
trop de pression ça sent
que tu fait merci ludwiig qui lâche des
infos l'information est tombée on va
voir comment la partie se terminer 5 que
la va être super cool les amis à suivre
ça va être
bouillant non le c'est c'est toujours sa
en
fait près de que en mustwin on peut
regarder un peu près de que si vous
voulez pour savoir qui va gagner le
tournoi mais bon il est en must win avec
un pion deement final
donc après moi j'aurais été capable de
refuser nul avec les Noirs
oui oui oui oui non mais tu peux après
après tu te dis je fais nul je fais 3è
je prends quoi 60k 50k je perd je prends
pas tu dis ok vas-y non mais en fait si
c'est Ikar dit franchement qui se
qualifie je trouve que ça aurait été les
deux meilleurs enfin ikarou euh bon pour
ce qu' fait en général de toute façon il
mérite d'y aller et vidit si on fait le
cumule Coupe du monde ici franchement en
plus il fait sortir parabass fancar
ouais ouais non mais bon oui c'est que
justice rendue entre guillemets donc
oui et là en plus il perd la ronde 1
donc il s'est s'est vraiment bougé après
hein pour remonter
prochain champion du monde ben qui sait
il peut
vraiment je vais devoir acheter mon truc
ananas ah oui en Siou se qualifie ouais
mais je vais déjà en avant parce que tu
l'achètes
j en
ananas
prendre ce candidat à ce niveau ça va
pas BR bah après tu sais pas se qualifie
pour les candidats et il se remotive à
bosser de TR mois comme un fou et il
revient hyper fort
h genre là c'est que du manque de
travail hein c'est rien d'autre après je
sais pas combien il faut de mois de
travail pour revenir mais toute façon ça
peut pas faire de mal de faut bien
commencer à un moment a c'est en avril
je sais pas tu travailles à fond
décembre tu te REM à fond après bon tu
prends de semaines de pause mi-dcemb
machin tu bosses à fond tu vas jouer
févri tu rebosses février et début mars
et tu arrives frais comme un gardon et
tu es chaud enfin regarde le nombre de
joueurs qui va regarde Maxime là le
travail ça a finit par payer enfin il
revient quand même fort enin tu peux
revenir
quoi mais oui c'est pas de semaines
d'entraînement enfin c'est pas comme
dans les films où tu vois un boxeur qui
tape dans trois sacs pendant 30 secondes
c'est tu t'arraches quoi tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps et tu sues
on peut faire une petite pause l c'est
l'ORS de la
pause faire une petite pause occup-toi
deicha moi je remonte la fin de la
partie d' Caro et après je ferai la
pause quand ce sera signé on sait que
c'est signé officiellement mais ce qu'on
sait pas
c'est c'est c'est comment ça a été
signé
donc
donc on s'attend à tour à
6 tour prend à 5 et qui a plus de tour
se chiqué qui est nul donc voilà donc on
va
voir il a combien de dél il a un quart
d'heure seulement donc comment ça que
c'est fini et que ça fait déjà un moment
qu'on fait d'ici 5 minutes 10 minutes au
pire on aura vraiment l'annul ici non
non le tweet il est il est officiel hein
enfin le le le site qui donne les
apparillements du tournoi et qui suit
tous les résultats ça s chess results
ils ont déjà noté le résultats donc
après il devrait pas en fait les donné
temps à l'avance quand tu veux suivre et
qu'il y a un délai mais bon il nous
spoil il nous spoil après c'est pas
comme si là on a un spectacle de fou
c'est juste ah bah il y a pas eu besoin
voilà c'est officiel ici donc écoutez je
vais rejoindre keV en pause et et puis
on reviendra un pe vous montrer la fin
de la partie de vidit qui est là donc si
je sais pas si je mets un écran de pause
normal ou si je laisse vidite vu que
c'est ça qui intéresse
ouais tu
peuxou micro ouais c'est ça ben j'ai
déjà rangé le tien mais voilà bah
écoutez on fait la pause on revient on
vous laisse l'écran comme ça avec la
partie de visdite et euh et voilà à tout
de
suite
allez je suis de
retour et et donc on regarde cette
partie de viditit qui a besoin que d'une
nul pour se qualifier mais qui a
vraiment une belle
position qui a une belle position parce
ce cavalier là il est assez enfermé et
de deux à tout moment les blancs peuvent
prendre le pion en B7 et se donner deux
pions passés liés à l'eld dame qui vont
avancer très vite
donc donc en fait prê que de sald et
parti qui a bien tourné pour vidit mais
bon comme je vous dis comme il peut se
contenter de la
nulle il est large quoi il est large euh
donc il peut jouer détendu en se disant
au cas où je rate le gain bon ben je
rate le gain c'est pas grave après si g
il gagnera seul le tournoi donc bah ça
sera une performance de gros calibre
enfin même finir second c'est gros
calibre mais mais donc voilà Ikao a fait
nul Ikao a fait nul donc il a sécurisé
la seconde place à
minima il sera premier si vidit ne gagne
pas euh mais vidit a toutes les cartes
en M pour gagner alors après il a plus
moins que 2 minutes donc on sait jamais
mais
euh mais on va voir ce qui nous joue ici
est-ce qu'il fait t prend B7 est-ce
qu'il fait H4 pour garder son pion
est-ce qu'il fait peut-être 3 G2 pour
aller défendre et chasser cette tour euh
à lui de
voir et on me demande donc si firou donc
firou oello s'il fait pas de la merde à
la singlefield bah en gros oui mais tu
sais bon ça c'est un cas complètement
improbable mais même Maxime s'il te un 9
sur 9 à singfield il pourrait passer
devant
quoi donc il a fait ro G2 ok c'est
logique décal son pour attaquer la tour
et défendre son pion tour un
jouer donc en fait ils viennent de
répéter la position qu'ils ont déjà eu
et puis je sais pas donc si si visite va
juste répéter parce que bah ça le
qualifie au candidat et il est heureux
sachant qu'il est gagnant mais il s'en
fout c'est la qualife au candidat qui
compte monte ou si nous la joue pour le
gain il a une position gagnante mais ça
c'est lui qui
voit
euh franchement faire nul même en étant
gagnant euh ça se comprendra 1000
fois parce que
bon c'est euh c'était le but de son
tournoi c'est le but d'une vie quoi et
ben il la joue c'est incroyable il la
joue il a pris B7 donc bon B c'est un
choix de champion de faire ça bravo à
lui pour le spectacle c'est c'est bien
surtout qu'en plus maintenant il va
foncer son pion en fait on voit en plus
là bien ramener le roi de ce côté mais
s'il venit en D8 il se prenait tour ici
échec per le cavalier donc ilbligé
d'avoir le roi lointain et je crois
qu'il va ily à 5 et puis en avanting
quoi bonne chance pour arrêter ce pion
monsieur
Pr donc il joue pour la cayas mais il
joue aussi
pour bah pour l'honneur de de gagner ce
tournoi et
pour il joue dans le sens du jeu quoi
tuas une position comme ça tu veux pas
faire nul mais il y a tellement d'enjeux
avec nul qui suffit
que franchement j'en connais plus d'un
qui aura dit allez bon nul et je me
inclu dedans je
dire oui je sais que c'est 20k de gagner
par rapport à nul mais mais d'aller au
mais de prendre le micro risque de de
gaffer perdre et pas aller au candidat
ça te coûte beaucoup plus que 20k ça
donc après voilà c'est
le faut tu vois tes côes quoi mais il
pense pas comme ça c'est juste que je
pense qu'il a la certitude d'aller la
gagner et euh et donc il a choisi ses
coups pour ça maintenant le pion qui
fonce
ouais ouais nak dans les deux
premiers et c'est le 40e coup pour prê a
plus qu'une minute à jouer pour enfin
qu' a plus qu'une minute pour pour
trouver un coup et je sais pas trop quoi
lui dire de jouer enfin les coups blancs
sont assez simples c'est pousse pousse
pous en plus tu peux même
pas te dire tiens je mais là vas-y je
prends je pousse je fais ça parce que je
te fais échec au roi et et je te fais ça
donc en fait bah j'ai une tour plus à la
fin quoi donc ça ça va pas du coup euh
ben je sais pas trop je sa pas trop ce
que qu' peut faire enfin a priori il
peut rien faire
euh ça peut être abandon et donc bon on
arrêterai le stream là-dessus et ça sera
la fin du tournoi avec victoire de vidit
et nak second on aurait deux très beaux
qualifiés pour les candidats en tout cas
euh qui rejoindrait donc ceux qui sont
déjà qualifiés la Coupe du monde à
savoir pragananda
kwana Magnus ou abasov enfin plutôt
abasov à priori mais si Magnus
finalement dit ah non ben je joue bah ça
serait Magnus alors t 5 a été joué il a
pas encore abandonné mais je crois que
ça a poussé euh si ça a l'air
convainquant et euh qu'est-ce que je
voulais
dire et donc
vidit et prê de que et puis B nepo bien
sûr qui serait là aussi donc beau
plateau vidit est prê de que viditaka je
voulais dire et doncando non espeno a
perdu mauvaise partie aujourd'hui contre
Guiry trop de pression pour pour le
joueur russe il il a joué vite
l'ouverture il semblait bien connaître
ce qu'il faisait et puis un moment il a
plus trouvé les coups et sa position
s'est
effondré si dit Miss clic prê que
exactement mais là c'est dur de Miss
clic quand tu as un pion à avancer
euh tu pousses tu pousses tu pousses
quoi c'est pas comme sur Internet où tu
peux tu peux miscli tu reprends F7 ou je
sais pas quoi là c'est pas ta main qui
va aller donner une tour ou si tu te
déco là non tu es là donc ça va pas
échapper à vite tout
ça donc il va pousser et puis même si
les Noirs veulent ramener la tour pour
défendre sur la 8e de toute façon on
aura tour B8 soutenu par le pion à ce
moment-là donc B donc il y a rien à
faire hein c'est aussi simple que
ça je voir sur chess résul si déjà le
résultat si je peux vous spoiler
il a l'air de se battre pr
que qu' l' de s'accrocher ou vid se
balade ou je sais pas mais je pense on
encore pour un petit moment avant la fin
de la
partie mais bon
ok à si jouet ça c'est
logique
la place sera déterminé à quel moment
bah on sera cour mois de décembre mais
c'est la liste au 1er janvier donc au
1er janvier 2024 de toute façon ça sera
officiel à de coups de dame
exactemention et puis il y a personne
pour intervenir alors il a fait échec
donc le
roi bouger bon si on veut perdre c'est
pas trop possible si on fait il fait ça
on fait A7 et il nous mat voilà on a
trouvé un moyen de perdre
mais bon évidemment il va pas le faire
il
[Musique]
va non c'était bien et je viens de tout
mettre sur m au d'All c'estement fini
non ah bah oui c'est
fini en gros faut pas faire même just
non je all voir en fait bizarrement ils
ont pas
résultat donc je sais pas ce que ça
attend
mais donc oui bon çaattend plutôt à à
roi F2 quoi tu le 4 échec roi
E3 cavalier va bouger quelques part on
pousse à 7 et voilà ONF de jouer 4 qui
D6 mais à 7 quand même a 7 qui prend B7
à8 dam prend B7 je vois pas pourquoi ça
joue encore en fait que c'est qu'on a
15000 c'estfin le se comment tu peux
jouer 15 minutes de plus
quoi c'est le dernier match euh ouais
c'est le dernier match à en jeu du
tournoi en fait
qui encore gagné aujourd'hui
c'est le dernier match qui a un enjeu
etou ça
joue ça
joue un pion de plus mais bon il va se
faire bloquer et puis il va se passer ok
firou ça va faire nul par aussi a gagné
il paraî d'accord al c'était pas c'est
anecdotique en soi mais c'est bien pour
lui il finit dans le top 10 et pour ses
points c'est cool et donc là on s'attend
juste à à
7 il va même faire mieux que top 10 par
va peut-tre faire top 6 7 a 7 ou tour B8
échec 7 qui gagné aussi qui fait 7 quand
même au final
ouais non bon petit tourno prendre en
fait il était jamais dans le coup pour
la Calif mais il a rien perdu du tournoi
déjà et donc pas mal
B qui a encore perdu aujourd'hui
contreyen mais c'est
trop ri contre mais c'est quand même
très très faible quand tu vas au
candidat il va faire 18 point sur le 19
po quoi ouais on espère change d'Ave en
fait va faire une per 25 50 t le
tour
même les autres quand ils sont un peu
derrière un peu en D ou quoi qui fait
pas un super tour il fait quand même 7
quand même 7 ouais donc à 7 jouer il
laisse allaigrement sa tour pour faire
une promotion
d'âchec mais pour quoi faire c'est le se
qui
parle c'est le se qui parle
Fab il veut enfin il veut un truc sert à
rien ce serait tour des5 qui prend tu
fais dam il fait c des8 et il perd pas
la maison mais bon tu vas quand même
gagner mais oui c'est ça enfin bonà
c'est possible d'abandonner mon
ami je suis revenu vers les tour 5
encore mais bon
mme4
h mon
truc très
[Musique]
bien34ore bon tu fais H4 mais dam échec
t prend F7 et dam prend4 mais bon il va
te faire t prend
B5 mais ro F1 ça pas mal T51
enfin bon on se quittera à la suite de
cette partie vu qu'on connaîtra les
qualifiés et le classement du tournoi
l'essentiel
euh les Français ont fait nul
aujourd'hui alors c'est pas encore
officiel mais ça fera nul aussi donc
qure nuls et euh et voilà euh tournoi
joli tournoi deux deux beau qualifié on
ch un jouer et cavali 4
dernier piège espère le mouse
slip
ça te fait plaisir quoi tu perds mais tu
as menacé mat tu as fait une menace de
la partie au moins
quoi que sinon je suis pas sûr qu' en a
[Musique]
une non mais fait une menace de la
partie
quoi jamais quoi B bravo viit qui gagne
le tournoi avec 8 et dem sur 11 en ayant
perdu la première oua que il a enchaîné
victoire Gupta colar Shirov nul n
victoire nan sindarov nul nakapenko
victoire de PR ouais c'est c'est costaud
c'est très costaud merci d'avoir suivi
en notre compagnie ce grand Suisse qui a
été long parfois mais aussi assez
excitant à d'autres à d'autres égards
ouais et ouais alira bon on va pas
suivre jusqu'à la fin de toute façon
c'est anecdotique et en plus c'est
complètement nul hein la position et on
se retrouve donc très bientôt pour la
suite des tournois il y aura le
championnat d'Europe par équipe je sais
pas si on le suivra ou pas mais surtout
la S field Cup qui sera qualif dernière
place entre guillemets éligible pour les
français et on verra si euh alier Reza
réussit à maintenir son avance sur West
leso et ce ne sera pas mince à faire
merci à tous à bientôt ciao ciao